l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par Monsieur Paul Molac
pour le groupe liote
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
au nom de mon groupe je souhaite avoir
une pensée émue et exprimée un soutien
que j'espère uneanime dans notre
assemblée pour Yannick Moret mère de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins alors Atlantique
contraint
[Applaudissements]
contre un à la démission à la suite de
l'attaque inexcusable de son domicile
par le de la part de l'extrême droite
nous devons condamner toutes les
violences en particulier celles contre
les mers et élu locaux s'attaquaient aux
élus c'est s'attaquer aux vivre ensemble
c'est s'attaquer au fondement de notre
contrat social c'est s'attaquer à la
République
nous avons découvert il y a plusieurs
semaines avec un certain effroi le
témoignage du maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins faisant état de
nombreux intimitations violentes qu'il a
subi il a expliqué avoir reçu comme seul
soutien de l'État un unique coup de
téléphone de la part du porte-parole du
gouvernement le jour où sa maison a été
incendié il affirme n'avoir obtenu
aucune protection politique bien qu'il
en ait fait la demande de manière
répétée la réponse de l'État n'a pas été
à la hauteur du danger alors que c'est à
l'état de protéger et c'est l'État qui
voulait mettre en place une cada sur sa
commune les prises de position au
gouvernementale en soutient aux élus
victimes de violence au-delà d'être
tardive ne sont pas suffisantes ces
volions se multiplient que ce soit à
Callac que ce soit un peu grises quand
ou dans bien d'autres lieux qu'on vient
de tout mettre en oeuvre pour retrouver
une société apaisée avec des relations
respectueuses entre les administrer leur
représentants qu'ils soient élus locaux
parlementaires madame la Première
ministre quand visagez-vous pour faire
cesser ces violences et assurer au
quotidien la sécurité des élus locaux
sans lesquelles notre démocratie ne
pourra pas fonctionner
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Molac au nom du gouvernement au nom de
la première ministre qui s'est exprimée
au nom du Président de la République
nous voulons vous associer évidemment
aux propos que vous avez tenus de
soutien envers Monsieur le Maire de
Saint-Brévin et de tous les élus de la
République quel que soit leur conviction
et leur bord politique ils sont menacés
dans leur fonction dans leur intimité et
évidemment aucune cause
aucune cause ne mérite la violence
contre les élus quel qu'il soit je veux
monsieur le député vous dire évidemment
que nous avons tous été très choqué non
seulement des attaques connues Monsieur
le Maire mais de nombreux maires en
France qui connaissent aujourd'hui des
menaces quelle que soit les raisons pour
lesquelles il s'engage pour faire
respecter l'ordre public sur leur
territoire pour faire respecter leur
environnement ou leur vie et la vie
économique ou encore très récemment
lorsqu'il lutte contre les trafics en
tout genre monsieur le député bien sûr
lorsqu'un maire est menacé quand sa
famille est menacée bien sûr lorsque on
prend gravement atteinte à sa vie
personnelle en mettant des photos sur
les réseaux sociaux en le menaçant
physiquement en brûlant sans doute ces
véhicules et c'est bien et lorsqu'il
démissionne c'est un échec pour la
République et nous pourrions toujours
faire mieux mieux dans la prévention et
avec Christophe Béchu en charge des
collectivités locales et Dominique
forges je sais que tous les jours ils
sont au côté de de ces élus locaux très
courageux mieux dans la protection et
c'est le cas bien sûr du ministère de
l'intérieur des policiers et des
gendarmes et mieux dans la condamnation
et c'est sûr que le travail du garde des
sceaux aujourd'hui en lien avec les élus
et très important puisque vous savez que
les enquêtes judiciaires ont été
ouvertes immédiatement par le procureur
de la République et qui ne m'appartient
pas ici de les commentaires je veux
cependant dire que Olivier Véran membre
du gouvernement a appelé le maire de
Saint-Brévin la gendarmerie a pris trois
fois contact avec lui sans doute que la
protection n'était pas à l'auteur de ce
qu'il attendait sinon il n'aurait pas
démissionné sans doute nous pouvons nous
améliorer mais soyez certains qu'il n'y
a pas la main qui tremblent contre tous
ceux qui menacent les élus de la
République merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur Molac oui monsieur le
ministre je crois qu'en fait il y a il
faudrait peut-être avoir des procédures
spéciales pour pouvoir protéger
véritablement ses élus parce que
visiblement lui n'a pas été protégé en
tout cas c'est le sentiment qu'il a
donné dans ce qu'il a pu dire à la télé
voilà et dans la et je souhaite
évidemment que l'apaisement revienne à
la fois dans ce pays dans cette
hémicycle et je pense que le
gouvernement a une grande importance
là-dessus merci beaucoup la parole est à
monsieur le Président Chassaigne pour le
groupe Ghost démocrate et républicaine
madame la Première ministre le président
de la République s'adressant aux
français s'était donné 100 jours pour
apaiser leurs colères une colère immense
et pour cause sa réforme des retraites a
été élaborée sans négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux sans dialogue avec
les forces politiques promulguer sans le
vote des représentants du peuple
pomulgués malgré une mobilisation
massive des salariés du privé du public
des jeunes comme des retraités de la
France dans sa diversité depuis le 1er
jour de la mobilisation contre cette
réforme cette France s'est levée quand
on le recule le lâche de départ à la
retraite elle s'est mobilisée pour
revendiquer le droit de vivre dignement
à tout âge elle s'est insurgée contre le
47 ans contre le 44,3 contre le 49-3
contre toutes vos manœuvres pour imposer
votre réforme elle a aussi espéré un
référendum quatre mois de mobilisation
pour exprimer soif de justice sociale et
de respect hier le président de la
République a une fois de plus était dans
le déni de cette réalité dans la droite
ligne des propos tenus par différents
membres de gouvernement il a osé
prétendre que cette France mobilisée
n'était pas la France que votre
gouvernement serait trop intelligent
pour être compris de cette France là les
100 jours ne sont que provocation de
grâce arrêtez-vous là cessez de piétiner
le peuple et ses représentants cessez de
faire croire que l'extrême droite serait
la seule opposition respectable
cesser de diaboliser vos opposants le 6
juin sera grand le grand rendez-vous de
cette France qui vous encombre le 8 juin
nous porterons ici même la voix de cette
France en votant l'abrogation de la
réforme des retraites ce vote vous ne
pourrez
l'empêcher vous ne pourrez l'empêcher
même si ce doit être votre Waterloo
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président un
peu de silence s'il vous plaît la parole
est à madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Chassaigne il y a un an le
président de la République m'a fait
l'honneur de me nommer Premier ministre
et depuis nous avons continué à mener
les réformes nécessaires et à répondre
aux préoccupations des Français pouvoir
d'achat des conjugués
réforme de l'assurance chômage réforme
des retraites 27 textes ont été adoptés
quand certains misés sur le blocage nous
avons agi nous avons avancé mesdames et
messieurs les députés comme le président
de la République l'a rappelé hier
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
d'apporter des réponses concrètes à nos
concitoyens avec des résultats rapides
c'est la feuille de route que j'ai
présentée le 26 avril dernier alors nous
voulons gagner la bataille du plaine
emploi depuis six ans grâce à nos
réformes nous avons créé 1,7 millions
d'emplois et le chômage est au plus bas
depuis 15 ans
nous voulons poursuivre notre
réindustrialisation c'est le sens du
projet de loi industrie verte présenté
ce matin un conseil des ministres nous
voulons continuer à lever les freins à
l'emploi et permettre aux acteurs de
travailler davantage ensemble c'est le
projet de loi sur le plein emploi qui
sera présenté prochainement nous voulons
que la richesse créée bénéficie à tous
et nous allons transcrire fidèlement
l'accord sur le partage de la valeur
nous devons améliorer les conditions de
travail et de rémunération et je
commencerai tout à l'heure une série de
concertations avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales monsieur le
Président Chassagne j'en suis convaincu
le dialogue social c'est la meilleure
façon de répondre aux attentes des
salariés
mesdames et messieurs les députés
agir agir pour les Français c'est
continuer à prendre à bras le corps
l'enjeu de la transition écologique et
mener une planification écologique
ambitieuse et là encore beaucoup de
chantiers ont été lancés vous le savez
monsieur le Président Chassaigne avec
votre groupe nous avons voté la loi sur
le nucléaire ensuite les Français nous
demandent plus de services publics ils
demandent des solutions en matière de
santé et d'éducation assurer les
remplacements de courte durée des
professeurs permettre aux malades
atteints de maladies de longue durée
d'avoir un médecin traitant voilà des
progrès concrets attendus pour les par
les Français que nous réaliserons d'ici
la fin de l'année mesdames et messieurs
les députés nous devons enfin garantir
l'ordre républicain en déployant de
nouveaux effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie en préparant dans la
concertation un texte sur l'immigration
en assurant notre souveraineté avec la
loi de programmation militaire dont vous
débattrez la semaine prochaine en
renforçant l'efficacité de notre justice
tout en veillant à la maîtrise de nos
finances publiques monsieur le Président
Chassaigne le cap est clair l'action et
les solutions au service des Français
avec la majorité et avec tous les
parlementaires de bonne volonté nous
allons continuer à agir je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Ellie califère
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente après un
bulle j'immerai au nom de mon groupe
adressé un message fraternel à tous les
élus de la République victimes
d'intimidation et de violence
je pense ici aussi au maire de Monaco en
Guadeloupe injustement agressé mais je
pense surtout au courageux mère
démissionnaires de saint-brivet nous le
disons face aux agressions et aux
menaces à particulier celles de
l'extrême droite nous ferons toujours
front pour défendre nos élus font pour
défendre la République et les valeurs
d'égalité de solidarité de fraternité
je viens maintenant à ma question qui
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
Outre-mer face à l'explosion des prix
des billets d'avion tous les élus des
Outre-mer tirent depuis plusieurs mois
la sonnette d'alarme tous dénoncent à
l'unisson le caractère artificiel de
cette flambie tous vous apporte aussi
des solutions de bon sens mais alors que
l'été approches alors que nous étudiants
cherchent désespérément à retrouver
leurs familles rien ne bouge si ce n'est
que les prix augmentent pour contrer
cette explosion tarifaire une idée
soi-disant lumineuse refait surface
depuis quelques jours cette idée c'est
celle de la création d'une compagnie Air
outre-mer
une super compagnie fusionnant tous les
acteurs du secteur un mastodonte aérien
qui se partagerait le ciel avec Air
France pour les vols à destination de
nos outre-mer monsieur le ministre une
telle vision a de quoi inquiéter elle
inquiète d'autant plus que ce projet
serait Audi bah un fond d'investissement
qui va privilégier bien sûr les profils
et compagnies au pouvoir d'achat des
familles vous le savez la diminution de
la concurrence n'a jamais fait baisser
les prix bien au contraire ma question
donc c'est le gouvernement est-il
favorable à ce projet quel que soit ce
mur merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre délégué chargé des transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés les califères merci d'abord au
nom du gouvernement pour les mots que
vous avez eu contre toute forme de
violence et que nous réaffirmons tous
aujourd'hui sur la question que vous
soulevez que je suis le prêt avec le
ministre Jean-François caraco je veux
être très clair là-dessus vous avez
soulevé comme le député nior la semaine
dernière la question des prix des
billets d'avion pour revenir sur ce
point extrêmement important pour la vie
quotidienne je veux d'abord vous dire
que ces prix augmentent en partie en
large partie en raison de la hausse des
carburants que la hausse que nous
constatons malheureusement sur les prix
depuis à destination les outre-mer et
similaires même inférieur à la hausse
que nous voyons sur tout le trafic
longue distance en matière aérienne ça
ne veut pas dire que nous ne devons pas
agir précisément c'est le contraire qui
s'est passé je veux le dire aussi parce
que la Dom l'Agence des outre-mer pour
la mobilité à acheter cette année
soutenu l'achat de 60000 billets d'avion
dans le projet de loi de finances cette
année dans le budget qui a été voté
l'aide à la continuité territoriale
comme l'a rappelé le ministre Darmanin
la semaine dernière a été revalorisé à
50% c'est une mesure qui est en vigueur
aujourd'hui et qui a encadré les choses
mais nous devons aller plus loin en
effet avec plusieurs leviers vous les
avez évoqués d'abord pour être très
direct nous devons en effet maintenir je
suis content que vous le soulignez une
concurrence importante sur les liaisons
d'outre-mer et avec le ministre caraco
nous travaillons à sauver les offres
aériennes et des compagnies comme l'état
la fait d'ailleurs depuis 2020 avec des
investissements importants certainement
pas à réduire la concurrence ou avoir
une forme de monopole sur les outre-mer
qui ne serait je crois dans l'intérêt de
personnes comme nous a appris
l'engagement avec Jean-François caraco
avec Gérald Darmanin nous recevrons
aussi tous les ultramer qui le
souhaitent dans les prochaines semaines
pour faire un point sur cette question
spécifique et je convoquerai également
les compagnies aériennes concernées pour
avant l'été faire un point sur
l'encadrement des hausses pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de hausse induit ou durant ce
qui serait capté par des compagnies
aériennes mais là aussi c'est la
concurrence qui nous apporte une réponse
enfin avec le ministre caraco nous
lançons une refonte des aides de la Dom
parce qu'il est très important que nous
regardions comment ces aides peuvent
évoluer je le redis nous avons augmenté
le soutien cette année cela a un effet
important nous devons aller plus loin
plusieurs élus nous ont saisi en ce sens
et nous travaillerons avec vous pour se
faire si vous êtes d'accord dès la fin
de ce mois merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick Ory pour le comprenais sans
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre ancien maire de
Saint-Brevin je veux redire ici notre
émotion à la démission du maire actuel
Yannick Morez après une violente
agression et je lui redis toute notre
solidarité
cet événement est révélateur de
l'augmentation des violences qui
touchent les élus de la République je
les condamne toutes sans aucune
ambiguïté d'où qu'elle vienne il est en
effet inacceptable que dans notre
République les élus et en première ligne
les mers subissent des insultes des
menaces des intimidations du harcèlement
ou des agressions l'escalade la
surenchère et la banalisation des actes
violents auxquels nous assistons doivent
cesser des voies de recours existent
dans notre Constitution pour s'opposer
la violence qu'elle soit verbale morale
ou physique n'a donc pas sa place et ne
doit jamais être une réponse tout acte
de violence doit être dénoncée et se dès
le premier fait car à chaque fois ce
sont nos institutions qui sont visées
qui sont touchés et la démocratie qui
recule nous ne pouvons tolérer
l'instrumentalisation qui est faite par
des groupuscules politiques extrémistes
la République a besoin de ses élus car
ce sont eux qui font vivre au quotidien
la démocratie sur le terrain ils doivent
bénéficier d'une protection à la hauteur
de leurs engagements et responsabilités
madame la Première ministre pouvait nous
pouvez-vous nous dire comment le
gouvernement entend poursuivre son
action pour soutenir nos élus et les
protéger plus efficacement en
intervenant le plus tôt possible et le
plus fermement possible merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à madame
la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le députés Yannick Henry sans prendre à
un élu quel que soit son mandat quel que
soit son étiquette c'est sans prendre à
la République
[Applaudissements]
et ce qui est arrivé à Yannick Morez le
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins dans
votre circonscription monsieur le député
est inacceptable un qualifiable
Yannick Morez a été victime de la
vindique du harcèlement des
intimidations de groupuscules d'extrême
droite et la semaine dernière son
domicile a été incendié le gouvernement
est à ses côtés et je sais que la très
grande majorité d'entre vous le soutien
mesdames et messieurs les députés les
mers sont les visages de la République
dans chacun de nos territoires leur
mission est essentielle elle demande des
sacrifices et ils le savent mais les
menaces et les violences n'en font pas
partie alors je suis consciente monsieur
le député que condamné ne suffit pas et
mon gouvernement prend à bras le corps
la question des violences envers les
élus chaque jour avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur nous protégeons les mers les
parlementaires et tous les élus menacés
les préfets les policiers les gendarmes
tous sont au côté des élus pour les
protéger quand trop souvent ils sont
pris pour cible
cette action au plus près du terrain est
indispensable mais elle doit
s'accompagner de mesures plus
structurelles c'est pourquoi la Ministre
chargée des collectivités territoriales
Dominique Faure présentera demain à
dispositif pour mieux prévenir les
violences et accompagner les élus il a
été préparé depuis plusieurs mois
j'avais d'ailleurs eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec l'ensemble des
associations d'élus sur cette démarche
dès le 12 avril dernier il nous
permettra de mieux intervenir en amont
en repérant les menaces et de
sanctionner plus fermement les auteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés demain
je recevrai le maire démissionnaire de
Saint-Brévin ainsi que l'Association des
maires de Loire-Atlantique et
l'Association des maires de France pour
leur dire notre soutien et évoquer les
solutions que nous mettons en place le
civisme le respect des élus c'est le
fondement du pacte démocratique et
républicain nous continuerons à nous
battre pour les défendre je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Mathias Tavel
pour le groupe LFI
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mercredi dernier le maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins Yannick Maurice
démissionné quelques semaines plus tôt
le 22 mars un incendie criminel à son
domicile menaçait de le tuer ainsi que
sa famille nous voulons saluer ici cet
homme cet élu local son engagement pour
ses concitoyens
nous comprenons
nous comprenons sa décision car elle est
profondément humaine nous la comprenons
mais elle est une meurtrissure pour la
République ce maire a démissionné parce
qu'il était agressé par l'extrême droite
et abandonnée par l'État face à elle
c'est-à-dire par vous pourquoi a-t-il
fallu plus de 10 jours pour que le
Président de la République exprime sa
solidarité après l'incendie pourquoi le
ministre de l'Intérieur ne s'est-il
jamais rendu à Saint-Brevin pour
soutenir ce maire et le projet de cada
pour t'emporté par son propre ministère
le sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire a-t-il
vraiment refusé une protection
rapprochée à ce maire comme les cris
Mediapart pourquoi le préfet de
Loire-Atlantique n'a-t-il pas interdit
la manifestation du 29 avril laissant
l'extrême droite parader jusque sur les
marches de la mairie de Saint-Brévin
est-ce monsieur Darmanin qui a donné ses
instructions complaisantes avec
l'extrême droite lui qui trouve Madame
Le Pen trop molle ça suffit face à
l'extrême droite à son racisme assez
violence nous appelons tous nos
concitoyens se rassembler le 24 mai
prochain à Saint-Brevin
madame la Première ministre nous
apprenons par la presse des projets
d'attentat portés par l'extrême droite
visant le CRIF des mosquées le rappeur
Médine Jean-Luc Mélenchon sans que les
personnes ciblées par ces autorités
existe-t-il d'autres menaces de cet
ordre quand allez-vous enfin affronter
l'extrême droite au lieu de l'alimenter
par votre politique injuste et de la
protéger par votre inaction contre ces
violences allez vous renvoyer le
ministre de l'Intérieur
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Tavel
que l'émotion soit partagée c'est une
chose
qu'on évite les récupérations s'en est
une autre
j'ai été mère
comme Gérald Darmanin comme d'autres ici
les menaces les insultes les outrages
les fake news sur les réseaux sociaux
les mises en cause les invectives elles
viennent de partout quand vous êtes
maire elles viennent de l'extrême droite
elles viennent aussi de l'extrême gauche
la violence
la violence c'est trop facile
la violence c'est trop facile de la
condamner après
quand on avait vous
les conseillers régionaux et les filles
qui manifestent en disant Louis XVI on
t'a décapité Macron on peut recommencer
à quel moment votre indignation n'est
pas sélective
à quel moment dans la façon dont vous
vous exprimez ici vous n'encouragez pas
cette violence
les mères de France méritent mieux que
de servir de punching ball entre
l'opposition et la majorité la vérité la
vérité c'est que défendre les mers c'est
préserver la démocratie c'est commencer
par faire attention à la manière ici
dont on s'exprime ces témoignés du
respect quand un membre du gouvernement
ou quand un autre député prend la parole
ça n'est pas seulement monté en épingle
un fait divers tragique scandaleux ou
l'extrême droite est en cause dans
l'espèce c'est assumer dans tous les cas
de dénoncer les scandales et c'est
éviter d'appeler à la protection
policière quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon
explique que la police elle ne protège
pas mais qu'elle tue c'est ça aussi
c'est ça aussi la continuité alors au
milieu de tout ça au milieu de tout ça
soyez cohérent
combattons toutes les violences d'où
elles viennent avec la même force et
avec la même virulence mais là on fera
oeuvre utile pour la République et pour
la démocratie merci beaucoup
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Erwan Balanant
pour le groupe moderne
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente le groupe
démocrate s'associe au soutien au maire
de Saint-Brevin et à tous les lieux de
la République mais le groupe démocrate
est choqué que certains soient restés
assis nous sommes scandalisés
le vent nous
aujourd'hui les extrêmes sortent de
l'ombre des complexés espérant que la
République se meurt et que leur violence
est une solution
le fleuve de notre détermination
républicaine et démocratique ne peut se
tarir face à des minorités qui n'ont que
les armes de la peur et du mensonge pour
exister
n'oublions pas notre histoire la
République est un combat et nos droits
des victoires
cette violence assumée débridé qui mena
l'aise qui menace les élus nos
institutions et qui tabassent hier un
simple citoyen ne doit pas devenir la
norme et supplanter les véritables
actions citoyennes notre jeunesse
s'engage elle fait son quotidien combat
pour le climat l'éducation la solidarité
l'égalité la fraternité la liberté
partout des initiatives citoyennes
voient le jour et je voudrais ici les
remercier pour leur résilience et leur
abnégation ce sont elles qui
maintiennent la flamme républicaine
c'est à nous de porter ce suceau ce
sursaut civique et leur nez et leur
énergie au sommet nos institutions
dans cette hémicycle nous portons tous
une part de responsabilité dans ce
furieux engrenage certains ont oublié
que le débat et le compas politique ne
sont pas synonymes de violence
l'attitude policée de nos collègues du
rassemblement national qui reste assis
ne doit pas nous faire perdre de vue que
l'extrême droite est un danger pour
notre République
je vous rappellerai les mots de
Baudelaire
Baudelaire la plus belle des Russes du
diable et de nous persuader qu'il
n'existe pas mais alors Monsieur le
Ministre comment pouvons-nous apaiser
notre société et montrer merci
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Balan
d'abord depuis quelques années il y a eu
deux œuvres utiles d'un point de vue
juridique pour renforcer une bannière
concrète la protection des élus je veux
saluer la loi le corps nu qui a été à
l'initiative de cette majorité qui a
rendu possible le fait que il puisse y
avoir une protection renforcée pour
l'ensemble de ses élus et plus récemment
à la demande de l'Association des maires
de France le 24 janvier dernier une loi
a rendu possible à la fois pour les deux
chambres du Parlement mais également
pour l'ensemble des associations d'élus
de pouvoir se porter partie civile aux
côtés de ceux qui sont directement
menacés
la suite c'est la réponse pénale et
c'est l'accompagnement quelques chiffres
2256 c'est le nombre d'atteintes en
2022 à des élus
c'est un chiffre en forte augmentation
plus de 30% par rapport à l'année qui
précède dans 70% des cas
il s'agit d'insultes de menaces
d'invectives mais dans 30%
d'acte dans lequel l'intégrité physique
des élus peut être mise en cause
l'année dernière
ce sont pas moins de 650 réponses
pénales qui ont été apportées un titre à
un autre et depuis le début de cette
année ce sont des centaines de
procédures qui ont été lancées et déjà
171 sanctions pénales qui ont été
prononcées
protéger nos élus c'est pas seulement
ces mouvoir c'est bien sûr être capable
de condamner avec la plus grande force
les attaques d'où elles viennent en ne
faisant pas d'indignation sélective mais
c'est renforcer de manière concrète les
mesures mais les symboles ont un sens et
je vous rejoins monsieur le député ça
n'est pas anodin de rester assis quand
on met en cause l'honneur d'un déluge
au regard de toutes les nuits où il se
lève pour préserver leur concitoyens et
pour les accompagner se lever quelques
instants c'est un geste républicain
merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Kevin mauvais
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues cette question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre mensonge
voilà un mot qui résume la macronie
depuis des mois vous nous répétez que
l'inflation va ralentir que le pouvoir
d'achat va augmenter vous nous annoncez
maintenant une baisse des prix de
l'alimentaire de 5%. quel honte quel
honte de mentir aussi effrontément aux
Français même TF1 peine à comprendre vos
calculs et vos sources
mensonge encore quand la ministre Olivia
Grégoire nous annonce une baisse de 13%
des prix dans le panier entier inflation
annonce aussitôt ridiculisé par les
associations de consommateurs
compétentes que vous insultez désormais
mélinsey lui-même indique que les prix
de l'alimentaire explosent avec en
moyenne près de 15% d'inflation sur ces
produits jusqu'à 30% sur la viande ou
20% sur les pattes
je vous invite à aller dans un
supermarché pour faire des courses et
non des photos pour faire votre plein de
courses et non pour boire les 12 paroles
d'un géant de la distribution trop de
mensonges entraîne la contradiction
pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie se sont obligés d'intimer
l'ordre au distributeur de baisser leur
prix d'ici fin juin en réouvrant de
Vennes négociations si les prix ont déjà
baissé comme la première ministre nous
l'a indiqué madame la Première ministre
la baisse des prix de l'alimentaire ne
se décrète pas par 49-3 monsieur le
ministre de l'Économie la baisse des
prix de l'alimentaire ne se décide pas
dans un roman dont vous écrivez
l'histoire incapable ce sont ces mots
qui reviennent dans la bouche des
Français sur les marchés et dans les
supermarchés quand ils voient le montant
de leur plein de courses exploser et
qu'il vous entendent incapable d'agir
efficacement vous mentez encore sur
l'impact positif pour les Français de la
proposition de Marine Le Pen de
supprimer la TVA sur son produit de
première nécessité alors madame la
Première ministre quand allez-vous
arrêter de mentir aux Français quand
allez-vous reconnaître l'échec de votre
politique sur le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation est surtout quand allez-vous
penser aux Français à les protéger et à
les aimer
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des PME du
Commerce de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme
[Applaudissements]
monsieur merci madame la Présidente si
tant que la réponse à la question posée
intéresse ce qui m'accuse aujourd'hui de
mentir je suggère de répondre le
mensonge il est là le mensonge il est là
le mensonge c'est faire croire que
supprimer la TVA sur 100 produits de
première nécessité ferait baisser
l'inflation le mensonge il est faire
croire qu'en baissant cette TVA regardez
nos amis espagnols l'inflation
alimentaire
disparaîtrait mensonge le mensonge ça
fait 18 mois que vous l'entretenez entre
mensonges et fainéantis d'ailleurs mon
cœur balance l'inflation galope mais le
rassemblement national n'a qu'une seule
proposition depuis deux ans pour
accompagner les Français les courses
nous les faisons et je pense même que
nous les faisons bien plus que beaucoup
d'entre vous si j'en crois la faiblesse
de vos propositions on va être très
précis parce que les Français méritent
des explications à la suite de vos
accusations la direction en général de
la concurrence et de la répression des
fraudes à analyser pas moins de 1700
produits je sais que la précision vous
intéresse pas mais l'intéressera
peut-être ce qui nous écoutent
1700 produits qui ont effectivement été
décortiqués démontrant une baisse de 13%
en moyenne chez les distributeurs Auchan
Carrefour Casino Cora Franprix et
Système U je précise parce qu'on parle
d'études que cette étude a été faite par
la DGCCRF entre avant le trimestre
anti-inflation et après sa mise en
oeuvre il n'y a pas de sens à comparer
des produits entre après la mise en
œuvre et il y a quelques semaines nous
nous sommes d'ailleurs expliqués la
dgssrf à communiquer pas plus tard
qu'hier vous intéresse éventuellement
avec une calculette vous ferez
l'exercice vous même le prix du panier
est passé de 3439 euros à 3000 3 euros
ça fait
12,68%, vous m'accorderez à dire 13 et
le cas échéant ça vous évitera de
rencontrer n'importe quoi et à minima de
m'accuser de mensonges je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur Alexandre
portier pour le couplet républicain
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Pape
Ndiaye ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse
ça y est Monsieur le Ministre enfin ça y
est l'éducation nationale va enfin être
première quelque part oui l'éducation
nationale va décrocher la palme du plus
mauvaise employeur de France et ça c'est
à votre réforme du lycée professionnel
qu'on le doit alors évidemment en tant
que député je peux me rejoindre et me
retrouver dans certains des objectifs de
cette réforme mais en tant qu'enseignant
par contre je ne peux qu'être très
choqué de la méthode et des propos que
vous avez employés vous prévoyez des
fermetures de filières 80 à la rentrée
les enseignants s'inquiètent vous leur
répondez je cite qui peuvent se diriger
vers le professeur à des écoles ou vers
le collège
j'ai cru que c'était un canular j'ai
vérifié mais non la blague était
sérieuse si je vous suis les enseignants
en vente ou en gestion vont dorénavant
enseigner la lecture en CP ou l'Europe
médiévale en 5e c'est bien ça
dans quel monde vivez-vous c'est comme
si on vous débarquait messieurs le
ministre pour vous mettre à l'industrie
ou au finance totalement inconcevable
monsieur le ministre allez une semaine
dans une classe et vous comprendrez que
ce ne sont pas les mêmes métiers pas les
mêmes concours pas les mêmes choix de
vie pour beaucoup vos propos sont la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
jeudi dernier avec notre président de
groupe Olivier marlex nous étions un
lycée professionnel à Montrouge un
enseignant a été jusqu'à parler de
dépotoir pour nous dire sa colère face à
l'état de la gestion des lycées pro en
France c'était le cri du coeur d'un
enseignant passionné et qui croyait en
ses gamins mais qui n'en pouvait plus du
mépris de l'institution pour cette
filière qui devrait être la voie royale
et non pas la voix de garage alors
Monsieur le Ministre pourquoi un tel
mépris pour les enseignants du lycée pro
je vous remercie monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
député de son professionnel
il est pas là merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député portier je crois que
nous partageons largement ici le constat
de cette transformation du lycée
professionnel qui doit accompagner une
meilleure réussite des élèves et
accompagner ce lycée professionnel pour
qu'il devienne une voix de choix une
voix qui soit reconnue par l'ensemble de
la société pour cela nous allons donc
travailler sur les fragilités de ces
élèves pour mieux les accompagner mieux
les faire réussir dans ce parcours de la
voie professionnelle mais nous allons
également rapprocher le lycée de
l'environnement économique qui est le
sien et mieux préparé les élèves à leur
avenir professionnel cela passera et
vous le savez par un bureau école
entreprise par des stages dont la durée
sera augmentée en terminale et notamment
pour ceux qui souhaitent s'insérer
professionnellement ça passera aussi par
mieux préparer ces jeunes à la poursuite
d'études pour qu'il les réussissent mais
pour cela nous allons évidemment
accompagner l'engagement des équipes
professoral de l'ensemble des équipes
éducatif d'ailleurs par des moyens
inédits que nous mettons sur la voie
professionnelle c'est plus d'un milliard
d'euros supplémentaires que nous allons
engager sur la voie professionnelle mais
au-delà de ça ce sont des effectifs de
professeurs que nous maintenons à la
rentrée prochaine ce sont des également
400 effectifs temps plein que nous
mettons sur les lycées professionnels
pour accompagner l'équipe pédagogique
par le la voix d'infirmiers d'assistance
sociaux de CPE pour renforcer cette
équipe pédagogique et puis nous allons
travailler sur la formation des
enseignants notamment pour les filières
qui vont ouvrir et d'autres qui vont
fermer c'est un investissement majeur au
travers de France 2030 que nous allons
pouvoir faire 2,5 milliards d'euros pour
accompagner certes la mise en place de
nouveaux plateaux techniques mais
également la formation de ces
enseignants des proviseurs également de
lycées professionnels nous avons besoin
de ces enseignants nous comptons sur eux
ce sont des experts de la pédagogie et
notamment de la pédagogie au lycée
professionnel c'est avec eux que nous
devons faire le lycée professionnel de
demain et nous les accompagnerons pour
cela
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur porter allez-y madame la
ministre tout ça c'est de la langue de
bois les enseignants ne sont pas des
numéros les enseignants ne sont pas des
pions ce sont des personnes avec des
choix de vie un projet une vocation
enseignée c'est une véritable vocation
il mérite le respect et la dignité de la
fonction merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Charles Rodwell
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Économie des Finances 13
milliards d'euros d'investissements 8000
emplois créés c'est le bilan de
l'édition 2023 de Chris France qui s'est
tenu hier sur ma circonscription cette
édition est celle de tous les records
depuis 4 ans la France est le pays
européen le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers depuis quatre
ans les entreprises françaises et
étrangères nous réaffirment le même
message elles ont confiance en la France
elles ont confiance dans les fondements
de notre économie elles ont confiance
dans notre réponse aux crises
successives vous l'avez dit enfin depuis
six ans nous avons bâti une vraie
politique industrielle nous avons
massivement baissé les impôts pour les
ménages et pour les entreprises et nous
allons continuer nous avons réformé et
baisser nous avons réformé notre marché
du travail pour recréer 1,7 millions
d'emplois depuis
nous avons massivement soutenu notre
appareil productif à travers les plans
France 2030 et François Lens pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans la France
rouvre des usines cette politique
industrielle nous l'avons bâti au
service de toutes nos régions Dunkerque
ou le président s'est rendu vendredi en
est le symbole
6000 emplois détruits sur les 20
dernières années 16000 emplois créés
dans les 10 ans qui viennent
notre politique industrielle donne des
résultats nous allons l'accélérer c'est
l'objet du projet de loi industrie verte
que vous avez présenté ce matin monsieur
le ministre vous voulez accélérer nos
délais d'implantation industrielle en
préservant notre environnement quels
sont les mesures pour atteindre cet
objectif deuxièmement vous avez toujours
veillé à ce que la relance industrielle
soit juste pour bénéficier à toutes nos
régions quelles mesures proposez-vous en
ce sens je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la part de finances de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Charles
Rodwell
depuis le début des années
1980 la France a détruit 2,6 millions
d'emplois industriels fermés 600 usines
et la part de l'industrie dans le PNB a
chuté de 20 à 10%
. c'est la pire catastrophe économique
que notre pays est connu depuis 40 ans
depuis 2017 nous avons enfin au lieu des
incantations une vraie politique
industrielle nationale avec avec des
impôts avec une meilleure formation avec
un suppression des impôts de production
le résultat il est incontestable 300
usines ouvertes au lieu des 600 qui ont
été détruites 90
000 emplois industriels créés par la
politique de cette majorité par vos
décisions mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la majorité
alors maintenant nous voulons accélérer
avec ce projet de loi sur l'industrie
verte accéléré pour devenir la première
nation industrielle décarbonée en Europe
accéléré pour mettre à disposition de
tous les industriels qui voudraient
investir sur notre territoire des
terrains pour ouvrir des usines ou
agrandir les usines existantes accéléré
pour avoir des procédures
administratives avec des délais divisé
par deux nous voulons qu'en France on ne
met plus de 17 mois pour ouvrir une
usine mais neuf mois pour ouvrir de
nouvelles installations industrielles
nous voulons mettre à disposition les
financements nécessaires des subventions
des crédits d'impôts comme l'Union
européenne nous l'a autorisé et
également un nouveau plan d'épargne
verte pour les jeunes avec 0,1 impôts
zéro charge pour que les jeunes
investissent dans l'industrie de demain
et dans la décarbonation de notre
industrie enfin nous voulons
naturellement
favoriser et protéger notre industrie il
n'est pas normal que le bonus électrique
1 milliard d'euros Ayo véhicule produit
en dehors de l'Europe le bonus
électrique désormais sera réservé aux
véhicules produits sur notre territoire
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Yohan gilet
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur un contexte de
violence insupportable contre les élus
de la République amènent des élus de
tout bord abandonnés par l'État à la
démission au nom de mon groupe je
voudrais tout d'abord adresser à ses
serviteurs de la République tout mon
soutien dans ce contexte j'ai été alerté
la semaine dernière par un maire de ma
circonscription sur une occupation
illégale du domaine public par des
forains qui le sont en aucun cas
représentatif de la profession alors que
cette commune en accueille toute l'année
avec plaisir Sephora là ce sont accaparé
le domaine public on volait du courant
et menacé un employé municipal ils
entendaient donner des représentations
de sport motorisées sans les
autorisations préfectorales le maire de
Beaucaire qui entend assurer l'ordre
public à immédiatement saisi la justice
en référés pour obtenir leur expulsion
l'audience a eu lieu aujourd'hui après
la bataille abandonné par l'État ce
maire qui avait en vain alerté le
cabinet du préfet a donc décidé ce
weekend lui-même sur place pour alerter
protéger les habitants j'étais à ses
côtés avec de nombreux élus et agent de
la ville notamment la police municipale
face au rappel du droit certains de ses
forains ont alors outragé et diffamés le
maire mon violenté mon violenté un agent
de la ville et ont commis une tentative
d'homicide avec armes par destination un
camion à l'encontre d'un autre élu ces
élus dont l'indemnité mensuelle et de
moins de 200 euros à 5 jours d’idét
quatre plaintes ont été déposées et un
arrêté d'interdiction pris pour les
spectacles suivants suite à ces troubles
à l'ordre public et à ses violences
grâce à la ténacité et au courage du
maire ces spectacles n'ont pas eu lieu
dans beaucoup d'autres villes les élus
seul face aux menaces abandonnent de
peur des représailles pour autant c'est
délinquants ont indiqué à plusieurs
reprises souhaitées en représailles
venir à 300 et bloquer la ville jeudi
pour la grande foire de l'Ascension
monsieur le ministre trouvez-vous
admissible de laisser des élus seul face
à ces situations comptez-vous comment
comptez-vous gérer en termes de sécurité
publique la journée de jeudi dans cette
commune pourquoi un homme accusé de
tentatives d'homicide avec armes par
destination est-il toujours en liberté
72 heures après les faits la parole est
à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
ce qui est bien quelque chose qui nous
étonne et qui peut-être tu aurais pu
vous inspirer à la modestie ce n'est pas
d'avoir des mots pour le maire de
Saint-Brévin mais plutôt pour vous
excuser du climat par lequel parfois
vous mettez certains élus qui veulent
accueillir des personnes immigrées sur
leur territoire je pense que ça aurait
été à la hauteur de votre engagement
[Applaudissements]
et je et je pense que je pense qu'un peu
de retenue quand on voit les résultats
ce que donne parfois vos interventions
médiatiques et l'action parfois de vos
militants donne comme résultat pour
certains élus de la République
deuxièmement je vous ai trouvé beaucoup
moins agressif monsieur le député je
vais trouver beaucoup moins agressif ce
weekend quand vous m'avez fait appeler
plusieurs fois nous avons beaucoup
échangé avec mon cabinet et vous-même
vous avez pas eu un mot pour le préfet
pour la préfète en l'occurrence pour les
forces de l'ordre pour mon cabinet qui
tout le week-end ont répondu à vos
appels et ont dépêché les forces de
police dommage de ne pas l'avoir dit ici
et je tiens à disposition les échanges
et pistolaires et textuels que nous
avons eu si vous souhaitez que mizon
intérieur gère le ministère de la
Justice en effet on n'a pas le même
conception de la République il y a eu un
recours la décision a été donnée elle
sera appliquée la différence entre vous
et nous c'est qu'on applique le droit de
la République
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Julien Bayou pour le groupe
écologiste
madame la Présidente ma question est
pour le ministère de l'Agriculture il y
a 60 ans l'écologie Rachel Carson alerté
sur les dangers des pesticides et de
l'agriculture intensive dans le livre
printemps silencieux elle était moquée
et c'est désormais attesté les
pesticides et l'agriculture intensive
sont responsables de la disparition de
20 millions d'oiseaux par an comme la
teste une étude publiée hier que tout le
monde comprenne bien cette étude est
qualifiée comme par le CNRS comme la
plus complète jamais réalisée 37 ans de
données sur 28 pays 170 espèces et une
conclusion scientifique implacable
l'agriculture intensive est responsable
en tout premier lieu de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité
et vous que faites-vous
la bio n'est pas plus cher mais les
moins subventionnée elle est fragilisée
par votre choix de supprimer la demande
tiens et son prix est renchérit par les
marges des centrales d'achat la réalité
c'est que les magasins bio aujourd'hui
ferment et les agriculteurs bio ne s'en
sortent plus la filière se meurt et
pourtant il existe une solution simple
appliquer la loi la loi égali m'impose
20% de produits bio dans les cantines on
en est loin et avec ce débouché nous
pourrions sauver la filière et offrir à
tout le monde une alimentation de
qualité ce que nous vous demandons
aujourd'hui c'est aminima d'appliquer la
loi pour sauver la filière bio c'est
d'en finir avec l'addiction française
aux pesticides de faire le choix de
l'agriculture bio plutôt que de
l'agriculture chimique merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
bayou
d'abord
je présente les excuses de Marc feno qui
peut pas être là aujourd'hui mais qui
demain après-midi
aura l'occasion de présenter
des annonces en faveur de la filière bio
qui font suite à la réunion sur la
planification écologique et sur la
transition agricole qui a été présidée
par la première ministre le 4 mai
dernier qui s'inscrit dans le schéma de
planification écologique qui sera
présenté à la fin du mois de juin
la réalité c'est qu'on a une année 2022
particulièrement complexe après un
quinquennat ou en moyenne nous avons
connu 15% de conversion au bio par an et
avec des mesures prises par cette
majorité comme le crédit d'impôt en
faveur du bio qui représente pour 2023
110 millions d'euros d'efforts soit 50
millions d'euros de plus que l'année
dernière mais après ces 15% en moyenne
de conversion bio l'année 2022 elle a
été marquée par deux phénomènes d'abord
un tassement des conversions 9% mais
surtout par une montée préoccupante des
déconversions et on a eu plus de 3600
déconversions de ferme quand dans le
même temps nous n'avions que 5300
conversions et pourtant vous l'avez dit
les bienfaits du bio pour l'emploi 13 %
des fermes concentre 19% des emplois
pour la santé avec les études humaines
sur l'obésité sur le diabète sur
certains types de cancers sur la
biodiversité avec l'étude que vous citez
hier et plus largement sur la planète
sont avérés tout l'enjeu c'est bien dans
le contexte dans lequel nous sommes de
faire en sorte de prolonger les aides
déjà annoncées au moment du salon c'est
le deuxième pilier de la PAC dont les
crédits sont portés de 240 à 340
millions ce sont les annonces qui
arriveront demain et le crédit d'impôt
mais gardez-vous là aussi dans la
manière de présenter les choses d'être
trop manichéen il y a des réalités sur
le territoire des disparités le sujet ça
n'est pas que le bio c'est aussi le
local et c'est de faire en sorte qu'on
soit capable de joindre les deux en
termes d'emploi et biodiversité merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Marie Agnès poussier Vince
bac pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues la mort du
maire de cygnes les agissements glaçants
contre le maire de Saint-Brevin les
actes de violence d'intimidation dans
son victime quotidiennement les élus
locaux départementaux régionaux
nationaux européens sont inacceptables
est-il normal dans une démocratie que
certains de nos collègues nos enfants
nos conjoints nos conjointes et parfois
peur d'être reconnu d'être prise à
partie ou tout simplement de rentrer
chez eux chez nous
mes chers collègues je voudrais rappeler
que dans notre pays il n'existe pas de
bons ou de mauvaises élus selon nos
étiquettes selon les décisions que nous
prenons nous avons tous été élus au
niveau local national par le peuple et
les élections sont là pour nous
sanctionner ou nous renouveler la
violence ne serait jamais être justifiée
je suis consciente que des mesures ont
été prises récemment pour mieux
sanctionner de tels actes notamment
grâce à la loi engagement et proximité
qu'aujourd'hui les associations
nationales peuvent se constituer partie
civiles mais on le voit nous devons
montrer plus de fermeté comme l'avait
souhaité Naïma muchu notamment lorsque
de tels actes sont commis en récidivent
nous devons être plus ferme face à
toutes les violences mais nous devons
aussi permettre aux élus de mieux se
protéger d'être mieux protégé qui osera
demain se présenter aux élections si
nous devenons tous des cibles qui osera
relever demain les défis auxquels nous
le savons nous allons tout s'être
confronté qu'il soit écologique
numérique démographique si la violence
devient la réponse à toutes nos volonté
de changement l'annonce de la création
d'un centre d'analyse et de lutte et
d'atteinte aux élus est une bonne
initiative mais nous devons aller plus
loin quels moyens pourrions-nous mettre
en place collectivement pour que notre
démocratie continue à vivre dans nos
villes dans nos villages et dans nos
assemblées je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Bachut ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la dépousser poussiévince BAC vous
l'avez dit demain après-midi Dominique
Faure aura l'occasion de préciser ce que
ce centre de lutte contre les atteintes
aux élus aura vocation à faire
coordonnées
recenser faire également en sorte que
nous puissions disposer d'une analyse
qui soit beaucoup plus précise à la fois
de ce qui se passe et que nous soyons
plus réactifs mais connaître c'est bien
coordonner c'est mieux mais ça ne suffit
pas
il y a eu je tiens à le dire sous
l'impulsion du ministère de l'Intérieur
d'abord une action de sensibilisation à
tous les élus sont prêts à la minute où
je vous parle de 25000 élus qui ont
bénéficié de tant de formations avec la
gendarmerie pour savoir comment réagir à
une partie de ces atteintes plus loin
que ça
3429 c'est le nombre de gendarmes et de
policiers qui ont été spécifiquement
formés à l'intérieur du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour être les référents des
élus la suite c'est la réflexion que
nous devons avoir sur ce que c'est
violence à destination des élus
reflètent
nous avons ici
de façon presque unanime considérer que
le port de l'uniforme qui représente la
République devait être une circonstance
aggravante des peines contre ceux qui
s'en prenaient aux pompiers aux
policiers aux gendarmes le port de
l'écharpe même s'il n'est pas permanent
il reflète exactement la même réalité
celui de représenter les valeurs de la
République et de la manière dont vous
l'avez dit indépendamment des opinions
de chacun la légitimité elle tient au
fondement de la démocratie et dans notre
conviction qu'à partir du moment où un
homme et une femme et investi par la
majorité de ses concitoyens la manière
dont ils expriment ça n'est plus
seulement la sienne c'est une manière de
faire vivre la République dans les
décisions qu'il prend creuser cette
piste allez dans ce domaine ça fait
partie des sujets qui sont sur la table
je recevrai demain avec Dominique fort
toutes les associations d'élus ce sera
un des sujets que nous évoquerons
ensemble je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Emmanuel
Antoine pour le repérer républicain
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre alors que le Président
de la République cours dans toute la
France après sa popularité perdue sans
annoncer de véritables réformes pour le
pays pendant qu'il évolue dans sa bulle
médiatique entre cordon de sécurité qui
sur sollicite nos forces de l'ordre la
violence flambe dans nos territoires
notamment dans les villes moyennes la
semaine dernière en 4 jours seulement
trois meurtres se sont succédés à
Valence le quotidien des habitants des
deux quartiers concernés et hantés par
les échanges de tir et règlement de
compte sur fond de trafic de drogue et
de guerre de territoire mais cette
violence nous la retrouvons partout dans
le pays sur l'année écoulée les
homicides sont 30% plus nombreux qu'en
2017 nous assistons consternés à la
brutalisation de notre société cette
brutalisation qui peut nous mener à la
BIM comme la montrer l'historien Georges
Moss face à cet engrenage de la violence
la République doit faire preuve de Total
fermeté et il vous appartient en tout
point du territoire de garantir la
sécurité première des libertés or for
force de constater votre échec en
matière de lutte contre l'insécurité dès
lors rétablissez l'autorité de l'État
pour cela il faudrait davantage
d'effectifs de force de l'ordre qui font
au quotidien en dépit de moyens
insuffisants un travail admirable que je
tiens à saluer il faudrait renforcer le
continuum de sécurité en améliorant le
dialogue entre les maires et l'État et
en renforçant les pouvoirs des polices
municipales il faudrait redonner enfin
notre justice les moyens d'accomplir sa
mission alors que nos tribunaux à
l'instar du tribunal judiciaire de
Valence manque de moyens alors Monsieur
ministre quand allez-vous répondre aux
attentes légitimes de sécurité des
Français
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs débuter madame la députée il y
a eu à Villerupt et avalanche ces
derniers jours des règlements de comptes
des assassinats sur fond de trafic de
drogue vous le savez bien et notamment
dans le territoire de la Drôme il se
trouve que à Villerupt et à Valence mais
je laisserai évidemment la justice
communiquée les enquêtes avancent et les
personnes sont interpellées mettant fin
je l'espère être des responsabilités à
ceux qui se livrent des guerres de
territoire contre le trafic de drogue
pour lequel le gouvernement a utilisé
vous le savez des moyens sans précédents
et que vous avez accompagné d'ailleurs
en votant la loi que j'ai eu l'honneur
de proposer bien sûr ce qui se passe à
Valence est inacceptable j'y ai dépêché
une compagnie de cérèse l'augmentation
des effectifs au commissaire de Valence
et sans précédent vous le savez bien
depuis 5 ans alors que ces effectifs
avaient laissé depuis une vingtaine dans
le département de la Drôme tant aux
autres gendarmerie quand zone police
ceci madame la députée explique
peut-être en partie cela il n'est pas
tout à fait vrai cependant si vous me le
permettez et malgré ces faits divers
absolument inacceptables de constater
que la délinquance augmente notre pays
j'aurai l'occasion cet après-midi même
de rendre public les chiffres de
vacances de l'année et vous y
constaterez que le travail collectif de
la police de justice et des moyens que
vous avez voté puisque vous avez voté
les textes et j'espère que vous noterez
le texte du garde des sceau sur la
justice nous permettent pour la première
fois de faire reculer cette violence
dans l'espace public violence physique
tentative d'homicide et bien sûr
violence dans les transports en commun
la clé madame la députée c'est la lutte
contre la drogue la clé madame la
députée c'est l'action sans précédent
que nous menons tous collectivement avec
les élus locaux nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler si vous souhaitez sur les
polices municipales le Conseil
cautionnel ayant censuré les compétences
supplémentaires que nous souhaitions
données aux polices municipales pour
intervenir dans ce cadre là
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
madame Antoine monsieur le ministre les
chiffres sont là et les Français ne
partagent pas votre satisfaite ils
attendent avec urgence une une action
résolue contre l'insécurité qu'il vive
alors entendez les
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue
monsieur ministre
je les entends moi j'habite tous les
élus à continuer le travail qu'ils font
sur les caméras de vidéoprotection c'est
le cavalence et aussi lutter contre tous
les écosystèmes qui soient de drogue ou
islamistes et j'espère que cette pierre
également à Valence je vous remercie la
parole est à madame Béatrice Descamps
pour logo pilote merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la santé et de
la prévention monsieur le ministre selon
le baromètre France à Sao santé 37% des
Français ont été confrontés à des
pénuries de médicaments en pharmacie
cette année celle-ci ont été multipliées
par 30 en 10 ans et touche les
antibiotiques mais aussi les
anticancéreux les insulines les
anti-épileptiques rupture de stock
tension d'approvisionnement disent les
uns Sanofi évoque une problématique
industrielle calvaire résume les
familles qui se trouvent dans une
situation angoissante et dans une
profonde incertitude vous avez appelé
monsieur le ministre a des récits soit
une liste de médicaments essentiels dans
le but de recenser les points de
fabrication en fin d'assurer la
disponibilité à l'échelle européenne
également cela va se faire les acteurs
du secteur préconisent une harmonisation
des prix au niveau européen ainsi qu'une
relocalisation de la production pour
rappel 40% des médicaments de l'Union
européenne pardon proviennent de la
Chine et de l'Inde 60 à 80% des
principes actifs ils sont également
fabriqués monsieur le ministre quels
sont vos marges de manœuvre pour doter
notre pays d'une capacité de production
de médicaments de quelle façon
allez-vous pouvoir engager la
responsabilité de l'État conjointement
avec l'Europe pour assurer la continuité
de traitement face à la pénurie de
médicaments je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma chère collègues la parole
est à Monsieur François
Premier ministre de la Santé de la
prévention merci Madame la députés
madame la Présidente pardon mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députés
Descamps il existe effectivement des
tensions d'approvisionnement sur
plusieurs médicaments actuellement mais
fort heureusement sans risque de rupture
complète puisque ces médicaments sont
toujours disponibles ces tensions
peuvent être liées à des difficultés de
production des difficultés de
distribution mais également une
augmentation des demandes comme cela a
été le cas l'hiver dernier en
particulier tout le monde s'en souvient
sur le paracétamol et l'amoxicilline ces
derniers mois des mesures ont été prises
envers les industriels des mesures leur
imposant des stocks tampons justement
pour mieux nous approvisionner également
des mesures qui leur imposent des
déclarations en cas de risque potentiel
de rupture ce qui explique le nombre
d'augmentations de ces déclarations
également des mesures vis-à-vis de la
distribution avec un contingentement
c'est-à-dire une meilleure répartition
sur l'ensemble du territoire pour éviter
qu'il y ait des départements qui aident
des médicaments et d'autres pas le
gouvernement sur l'autorité de la
première ministre une politique de
mesure concrète contre ces difficultés
vous l'avez dit je me suis engagé à une
liste de médicaments dit critiques avant
la fin de ce mois elle existe déjà j'en
ai eu une première liste de 281
médicaments exactement aujourd'hui elle
va être encore ajustée parce qu'il y en
a qui qui marque des doublons cette
liste nous permettra de mieux étudier la
chaîne de production de chaque
médicament et de mettre en place des
mesures concrètes pour éviter les
ruptures il y a également un plan
hivernal puisque tous les hivers nous
augmentons la consommation de certains
médicaments également un plan blanc du
médicament qui est en train de se mettre
en place l'objectif voulu par le
Président de la République et de
retrouver notre souveraineté
industrielle cela concerne bien sûr
aussi le médicament comme c'est le cas
dans France relance France 2030 et
encore hier atchous France ou des
industries du médicament vont investir
plus d'un milliard d'euros dans notre
pays cette année justement pour
améliorer cette production nous agissons
aussi au niveau de l'Europe j'étais la
semaine dernière avec mes collègues
européens pour harmoniser nos politiques
dans le cadre des pénuries et c'est ce
que nous sommes en train de faire tu en
as même logique que la politique
conduite par la France vous voyez que
nous agissons sur tous les leviers
possibles pour garantir l'accès à nos
concitoyens de tous les médicaments
essentiels
Jean-Paul Lecoq pour le groupe GDR merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères il y a quelques heures nous
apprenions à l'occasion de la visite du
président
ellenski que la France outre la
livraison de matériel de guerre se
prépare à former des pilotes tout en
déclarant dans le communiqué commun
publié par l'Elysée que la France
fournira aussi des capacités complètes
dans tous les domaines
à quand les avions
dites-vous pas en train de franchir la
frontière entre la solidarité avec
l'Ukraine légitime et l'entrée en guerre
de la France les députés de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaines soutiennent
depuis le début du conflit le camp de la
paix pour favoriser toutes les
initiatives notamment parlementaires qui
accompagne le camp de la paix la voix
des pacifistes
Ukrainiens russes et du monde entier
doit raisonner elle est parfois
emprisonnée les opposants démocrates
aboutissent doivent être accompagnés
pour parvenir à la paix
quel que soit le moment des concessions
et des garanties de sécurité de part et
d'autre devront être faites parvenir à
des concessions semblent aujourd'hui
loin de se concrétiser car le prix de la
paix qui est celui de l'orgueil des
belligérants semble moins lourd à payer
que le prix de la guerre qui tue chaque
jour des êtres humains la seule
offensive diplomatique qui existe
aujourd'hui est portée par la Chine mais
on ne peut pas la laisser seule compte
tenu du blocage du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies que chacun mesure que
chacun comprend la réunion du G7 a
Hiroshima ce week-end ne serait-elle pas
l'occasion de travailler à un plan de
paix porté collectivement afin d'engager
au plus vite une offensive diplomatique
pour faire taire les armes sauver des
vies et sortir du conflit
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre des Affaires
étrangères et de l'Europe
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député le coq le
président de la République a reçu
dimanche le président zellenski comme
vous le rappelez et la France avec ses
partenaires et pleinement engagé pour
fournir à l'Ukraine tous les moyens qui
lui sont nécessaires pour assurer sa
légitime défense et le président de l'a
dit au président ukrainien nous allons
accroître nos livraisons de Charles
léger de véhicules blindés et de défense
anti-aériennes nous allons poursuivre
l'entraînement de soldats et engagé
celle de pilote de chasse nous
intensifierons aussi notre aide civile
et nous renforcerons les sanctions
contre la Russie vous mentionnez aussi
latence
vous mentionnez aussi l'intense
diplomatique qui s'est ouverte ce
week-end et qui va se poursuivre la
France il joue pleinement son rôle la
Charte des Nations Unies le respect de
l'intégrité territoriale le respect de
la souveraineté des États sont les
principes communs qui doivent fonder la
paix juste et durable que nous appelons
tous monsieur le député de nos vœux et
ses principes seuls peuvent permettre de
l'atteindre nous le rappellerons à nos
partenaires que sont la Chine le Brésil
l'Inde et d'autres
et enfin alors que Kiev vient d'être
victime cette nuit de nouvelles salves
de bombardements bombardement massif et
que la Russie constitue continue de
cibler les infrastructures civiles les
populations civiles je tiens à dire aux
Ukrainiens aux ukraines que nous sommes
à leur côté et que tout les auteurs de
ces crimes devront être punis
pour nos valeurs pour notre propre
sécurité et pour préserver les règles
qui façonneront le monde de demain
l'agression russe ne peut pas être
récompensée elle doit être défaite je
remercie
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Julie Delpech
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
comptes publics monsieur le ministre
vous avez dévoilé la semaine dernière
votre plan de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale qui sera suivi fin mai de celui
contre la fraude sociale votre partie
prix semble clairement affiché
concentrez les efforts sur les plus
grosses fraudes tout en allégeant en
même temps la pression sur les classes
moyennes votre méthode est claire plus
de moyens plus de sanctions pour plus de
résultats je salue l'ouverture de ce
chantier qui contribuera à redonner
confiance aux citoyens à ceux qui
travaillent qui participent à l'effort
commun par l'impôt et qui ressemble
parfois une forme d'injustice de
sentiment d'injustice surtout quand la
vie est chère comme ces derniers mois il
y a des attentes fortes et vous
démontrer à travers ces issues ces
annonces issues de contribution écrite
de la quasi-totalité des groupes
parlementaires qu'à l'idéologie
obsessionnelle de surtaxer tout le monde
tout le temps et partout vous préférez
le pragmatisme de de lutter contre la
fraude l'évasion bref de s'assurer que
chacun paye ce qu'il doit vous avez basé
votre méthode sur la relation de
confiance et le renforcement du droit à
l'erreur de grands progrès issus de la
volonté présidentielle si l'on comprend
bien les mesures dévoilées pour lutter
contre la fraude fiscale que pensez-vous
faire contre l'optimisation fiscale qui
apparaît aux yeux des Français comme une
fraude et qui pourtant n'en est pas
toujours une en effet certains
particuliers très fortunés ou certaines
grandes entreprises profitent de
certains outils comme le prix des
transferts abusifs ou bien des trusts
localisés à l'extérieur afin d'échapper
à notre fiscalité monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous détailler les mesures
que vous comptez mettre en oeuvre afin
de consolider la justice fiscale pour
tous et par tous je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Julie Delpech vous l'avez dit nous avons
pour ambition de lutter contre la fraude
et contre toutes les fraudes certains
veulent faire croire qu'il n'y aurait
que de la fraude fiscale d'autres qu'il
n'y aurait que de la fraude sociale nous
assumons de lutter contre toutes les
fraudes sans stigmatisation sans
instrumentalisation avec la seule
volonté de rendre aux Français notamment
de la classe moyenne qui travaille qui
respecte les règles ce qui leur est dû
c'est-à-dire des financements pour nos
services publics et pour notre modèle
social c'est le sens de la feuille de
route du plan de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale que j'ai présentée la semaine
dernière je veux d'abord rappeler tous
les progrès qui ont été permis ces
dernières années notamment par la loi de
2018 qui avait été portée par mon
prédécesseur Gérald Darmanin c'est cette
majorité qui a fait sauter le verrou de
Bercy et qui a permis un certain nombre
d'initiatives qui nous ont permis l'an
dernier d'avoir une année record en
matière de fraude fiscale identifiée
14,6 milliards d'euros il faut franchir
une étape supplémentaire aller plus loin
et vous l'avez dit la philosophie qui
est la mienne c'est plus de moyens plus
de sanctions et plus de résultats plus
de moyens ce sont des agents
supplémentaires pour le contrôle fiscal
1500 agents dans les 5 années à venir le
doublement des agents du service
d'enquête judiciaire des finances des
sanctions supplémentaires renforcées
pour les cas de fraude les plus graves
quand on est dans de la bande organisée
dans de la dissimulation d'avoir à
l'étranger on sort de la citoyenneté et
donc la sanction d'indignité fiscale et
civique selon moi est pleinement
justifiée dans ces cas nous y
travaillons avec Eric Dupont Moretti les
situations que vous évoquez sont celles
de cette fameuse zone grise vous avez
parlé d'optimisation fiscale certaines
situations qui se font sur des schémas
légaux qui en réalité se révèlent abusif
et quand c'est flou il y a un coût un
coup pour les finances publiques c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai annoncé
aussi un certain nombre de mesures sur
la régulation des prix de transfert pour
les multinationales au sein d'un même
groupe qui parfois peuvent se révéler
abusifs nous avons prononcé une amende
record d'un milliard 300 millions
d'euros l'été dernier et également sur
les sociétés éphémères vous le voyez
nous sommes au rendez-vous sur ces
sujets je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Julie le chanteur
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des outre-mer ou
plutôt devrais-je dire ministre de la
submersion migratoire organisée le
président de la République vient de
déclarer qu'il était prêt à faire tous
les référendum possible personne n'y
croit vraiment de surcroît il a expliqué
qu'il n'en ferait pas sur l'immigration
les Français devront attendre l'arrivée
à la tête de l'état de Marine Le Pen
pour pouvoir se prononcer sur cette
question fondamentale pour notre pays
pour son modèle social pour son identité
cette déclaration vient confirmer le
mépris du président pour l'expression
populaire et illustre votre bilan
désastreux qu'il s'agisse d'immigration
illégales ou légales la macronie n'est
pas à l'aise avec ce sujet de fait votre
vision dans le domaine est
diamétralement opposée à celle des
Français sur les 189 migrants débarqués
de l'océan de Viking dans le Var 123 se
sont vus refuser l'entrée sur notre
territoire dont trois fichiers s ils se
sont tous échappés sans exception
aujourd'hui où sont-ils qui sans souci
pas vous visiblement malgré les risques
de de vol d'agression ou d'attentat des
conséquences dramatiques pour la
sécurité des Français quant à
l'immigration légale et je ne parle pas
des réfugiés Ukrainiens qui bénéficient
à juste titre de notre hospitalité en
même temps que vous offrez le gîte le
couvert et tous les soins gratuits à
plus de 320 millilitres immigrés en 2022
soit l'équivalent de la ville de Nice
vous abandonnez 300000 SDF et 11
millions de Français en situation de
pauvreté qui ne parviennent pas à se
nourrir à se loger ni à se soigner mais
vous persistez avec un demi million
d'immigrés légaux prévus sur notre
territoire à l'horizon 2027 alors que
nos que nos prisons débordent des
dangers vous n'avez expulsé que 3615
immigrés illégaux alors que la plupart
des mineurs non accompagnés ne sont pas
mineurs vous refusez de les tester et de
les renvoyer chez eux la France n'est ni
un autre ni un hôtel ni un guichet
social et des français demandent la fin
des bons aspirantes de cette immigration
massive monsieur le ministre allez-vous
respecter la volonté du pape allez vous
protéger nos frontières et les Français
victimes de cette immigration anarchique
et massive que vous leur imposez mais
merci beaucoup la parole
est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente et Madame la
Députée devant cette question pleine de
pondération et de modération d'équilibre
dans les propos et de respect des
personnes des personnes humaines
je oui désolé je sais que c'est à propos
qui semble pas tellement vous toucher
mais il restait la personne humaine je
peux vous dire que ce que vous dites est
un mélange de complotisme de démagogie
et de mensonges
deux complotisme parce que
vous faites semblant de croire que
les biens vu qu'on m'insulte je me
rassoir ça ira peut-être mieux pour le
prochain question
c'est Tanguy est-ce qu'on peut juste
avoir un débat polype posé pas énervé
pour une fois ce que c'est possible
merci merci Monsieur Dory
complotisme parce que vous faites
semblant de croire que l'État organise
ce que vous appelez vous-même madame la
subversion migratoire est-ce bien
raisonnable savez-vous que tous les pays
européens sont concernés par la même
situation la détresse d'une grande
partie de personnes qui quittent l'Asie
qui quitte l'Afrique pour venir en
Occident que nous puissions accueillir
tout le monde c'est entendu mais faut-il
y voir un complot de l'état non
du mensonge évoquer trois fichiers sur
le scène Viking chère madame je ne sais
pas que vous étiez le patron de la DGSI
par nature ces personnes pas nature
madame
par nature madame les personnes
dangereuses se voir refuser l'accès au
territoire national mais si vous le
souhaitez ce serait bien volontiers que
les policiers qui tous les jours dans
des conditions extrêmement secrètes et
confidentielles travaillent pourraient
vous montrer leur travail mais vous
n'écoutez même pas ma réponse et
finalement en écoutant pas ma réponse et
en nous insultant que vous le faites à
chaque question gouvernement le but le
but madame n'est finalement pas la
réponse mais de faire pour de poursuivre
votre démagogie au service des peurs
parce qu'une seule chose qui peut vous
faire élire madame c'est la peur que
vous en tentez tous les jours et je
regrette que vous n'ayez pas eu le temps
d'expliquer les quelques réponses que
les plus beaux portées merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Madame Julie l'ère nowez pour le
groupe écologiste madame la Présidente
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
ministre la solidarité nos valeurs
républicaines ont-elles définitivement
perdue face à la haine depuis l'hiver
2022 les élus qui respectent nos
obligations républicaines en installant
des centres d'accueil ou d'hébergement
de leur commune sont victimes des
intimidations et des attaques de
l'extrême droite oui l'extrême droite
car ne nous trompons pas à l'origine de
ces délits de ses crimes c'est l'appel à
la haine de l'autre c'est l'idéologie
proférée par des groupuscules d'extrême
droite et relayées par des partis
politiques dont certains sont assis ici
sur ces bancs
la commune de Callac et son centre
d'accueil ont été les premiers à subir
ces attaques odieuses et c'est
maintenant le maire de Saint-Brévin qui
menaçait attaqué jette l'éponge voiture
brûlées et pan de mur noirci c'est ainsi
que est apparu la maison de Monsieur le
Maire le 22 mars dernier une situation
effrayante et absolument scandaleuse
qu'a vécu Yannick Morez et sa famille et
à qui je souhaite que nous réétérions
toutes et tous aujourd'hui notre profond
respect et notre plein soutien
c'est fait monsieur le ministre peuvent
être qualifiés d'attentat c'est un acte
terroriste voilà le vrai visage du
terrorisme d'extrême droite qui est bien
vivant sur notre territoire et sur
lesquels nous vous avons interpellé à
plusieurs reprises et qu'avez-vous fait
en 50 jours qu'aurait-il pu se passer si
Yannick Morel n'avait pas d'émissionné
monsieur le ministre malgré plusieurs
allèles alertes votre ministère n'a pas
agi n'a pas protégé ce qui devait l'être
or ce sont les fondamentaux de notre
République de notre démocratie qui sont
attaqués au coeur à travers la figure du
maire de Saint-Brévin comment dans le
pays des droits de l'homme est-il
possible de rester sans agir face à la
bête noire qui prospère en refusant de
nommer les choses vous vous rendez
complices de ces agissements commerciaux
et à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
Madame Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
débutez malgré députés je crois que à la
fois la première ministre Christophe
bech um avons répondu au drame qui
touche évidemment le maire de
Saint-Brévin je veux aussi dire aussi
qu'il touche beaucoup d'élus de la
République quel que soit en effet leur
mandat quel que soit leurs opinions
politiques et quel que soit l'effet qui
les poussent à ses démissions autant
morales que politique
vous savez comme Monsieur Béchu j'ai été
maire et quel que soit les projets que
vous menez ici effectivement c'est un
projet pour accueillir des personnes
migrantes ça peut être un centre
éducatif fermé ça peut être un projet
autoroutier ça peut être un projet
écologique ça peut être un projet
économique les maires de France sont en
effet surtout les mères des communes
rurales seuls face à la violence qui
monte dans la société tout ce qu'elles
viennent d'où elles viennent et je peux
constater que lorsque j'étais en
responsabilité municipale comme lorsque
je suis en responsabilité ministérielle
j'ai toujours vu les gendarmes les
policiers les préfets quelle que soit
les bords politiques et trop côté de ces
mers et Madame la Députée autant je peux
être totalement d'accord avec vous sur
la condamnation de cet acte la procédure
pénale dira qui est responsable elle a
été ouverte par le parquet et je n'ai
pas l'habitude de commenter ce que fait
la police judiciaire il communiqueront
au moment où ils auront des éléments à
communiquer à l'ensemble des concitoyens
mais il est tout à fait vrai madame la
députée que dans vos propos vous
semblent dire que jamais les gendarmes
ont été voir le maire de Saint-Brévin
c'est tout à fait faux dans vos propos
vous avez l'impression de dire que
j'aimais les gendarmes m'ont protégé et
et le centre futur d'accueil pour les
personnes migrantes et un certain nombre
de lieux municipaux privés au public
c'est tout à fait faux que le
sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire
que le sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire
comme le préfet de Loire-Atlantique non
pas contacté le maire de Saint-Brévin
c'est tout à fait faux que aucun
gouvernement n'est aucun membre du
gouvernement de la soutenu c'est tout à
fait faux monsieur Vérand l'a eu au
téléphone monsieur le ministre Béchu lui
a écrit ainsi que ce président de la
République ce qui arrive au maire de
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est un monsieur Jean-Luc
grattement pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Première ministre trois jours
à la Réunion accompagné de quatre
ministres d'un paquet de conseillers de
collaborateurs de média nationaux
privilégié mais surtout de 400
militaires de force de l'Aude de drones
d'hélicoptère pour quadriller le terrain
du jamais vu pour ce genre de visite les
journalistes rayonnés ont été méprisées
c'était au boycotter votre opération de
com dès le deuxième jour vous êtes
arrivés en fanfare mais vous êtes
reparti en Missou comme un enfant pris
la main dans pour de confiture mépris
des élus vous êtes rendus dans la ville
de Saint-Joseph s'invite sans inviter ni
même prévenir le meilleur et la député
de la circonscription vous perpétuez
ainsi la relation du dominant dominé
quant à nos préoccupations 10 millions
pour l'agriculture totalement
insuffisant pour tout l'outre-mer mais
rien sur le taux suffisance alimentaire
60 millions pour deux lycées réchauffés
déjà servi en décembre 2022 par votre
ministre mais rien sur l'inclusion des
élèves porteurs du handicap 30 millions
pour la mobilisation des ressources en
eau soit moins de 7 poissons du budget
global mais rien sur le rendement la
distribution la qualité surtout rien sur
l’allègement des factures d'eau rien sur
la chioté de la vie rien pour le pouvoir
d'achat rien pour le maintien à domicile
des personnes âgées rien sur la révision
du coefficient géographique la santé
rien pour l'emploi des jeunes rien pour
nos petites entreprises qui souffrent
rien sur les conséquences de votre
réforme des retraites en outre-mer vous
ne pouvez pas fuir comme cela vos
responsabilités rendez-vous le 8 juin et
nous allons stopper ici dans cette
mission votre réforme qui ne sert à rien
en revanche madame la Première ministre
dans le cas du psium qui tarde à venir
êtes-vous enfin prête à prendre en
compte nos propositions pour le
développement des Outre-mer
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs députés monsieur député les
propos que vous tenez envers la première
ministre envers la délégation de
ministre qui est venu à la réunion
aurait peut-être eu plus de sens si vous
étiez rendu à son invitation parce qu'en
3 jours je crois que vous ne l'avez pas
rencontré une fois et que vous n'êtes
pas venu une seule fois aux nombreuses
réunions qu'elle a faite avec les
acteurs avec les élus et de ce point de
vue nous remercions Madame Bello qui je
crois est dans votre majorité qui a
salué l'action et les annonces de la
première ministre c'est vrai monsieur le
député que vous auriez alors entendu les
60 millions d'euros annoncés par la
première ministre pour les deux lycées
qui vont se créer à la Réunion l'un pour
les métiers de la mer l'autre pour le
tourisme vert c'est vrai que vous aurez
entendu alors les 50% de subventions
annoncés par la promise pour l'habitat
dégradé qui touche l'île de la Réunion
c'est vrai que vous aurez entendu alors
la prolongation du travail fait pour le
logement social qui manque cruellement à
la Réunion et c'est vrai monsieur le
député que vous auriez entendu les 30
millions d'euros pour les ressources
hydrauliques mais vous préférez faire de
la politique politicienne ce qui nous
étonne peu vous qui avez traité de
traîtres monsieur le député de traîtres
puisque auprès de violence tout à
l'heure par quelqu'un de votre groupe
politique les sénateurs qui se sont
rendus à la vitesse de la première
ministre de la République retirez-vous
ces propos vous qui avez été soutenus
par le responsable départemental du
Front national dans votre élection
législatives le maire de palmiers de
plaine les palmiers vous qui n'avez pas
appelé à voter pour le président pas
fin de leçon de morale de LFI quand un
député était lui avec les voix du
rassemblement national et qui ne s'en
excuse même pas et vous
vous monsieur vous monsieur le député
s'il vous plaît un peu de regarder un
article du Monde qui me semble-t-il
n'est pas toujours favorable au test que
défend le gouvernement merci Monsieur et
vous monsieur le député qui n'avait pas
un mot pour la politique que nous venons
à la Réunion qui renforce
coucou monsieur le ministre
monsieur merci monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez que deux secondes
messieurs damanais c'est à vous de
retirer vos propos merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur philippe
Maillet pour le groupe socialiste
Présidente
je suis désolé mon cher collègue à vous
donc la parole est à Monsieur Paul
Christophe pour le gros horizon je vous
en remercie madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur midi du
travail du pénurple et de l'insertion
monsieur le ministre avec pour ambition
d'atteindre le plein emploi d'ici la fin
du quinquennat et de favoriser la sortie
de la pauvreté et l'autonomie et
l'émancipation par le travail la refonte
de l'accompagnement des allocataires du
RSA est au cœur du projet France travail
à cette fin et pour garantir la prise en
charge de toutes les personnes ayant
besoin d'un accompagnement avec
l'objectif de ne laisser personne au
bord de la route tous les allocataires
du RSA seront inscrits à france-travail
on découlera une entrée en parcours
rapide de tous et une meilleure
continuité des parcours d'un
accompagnement ainsi la question de
l'accompagnement apparaît primordial
dans ce dispositif notamment en
direction de l'insertion des
allocataires les plus éloignés de
l'emploi à partir d'accompagnement plus
personnalisés plus intensif et visant à
agir sur l'ensemble des difficultés
rencontrées à partir d'une orientation
et d'un diagnostic amélioré je peux
attester de l'efficacité de
l'accompagnement renforcé puisque nous
l'expérimentons dans le département du
Nord où nous observons entre avril 2022
et avril 2023 donc les chiffres sont
récents une baisse du nombre
d'allocataires par retour à l'emploi
supérieur à la moyenne nationale pour
autant au-delà de l'accompagnement
renforcé se pose la question des freins
périphériques à l'emploi que ce soit en
matière de mobilité de logement ou de
mode de garde par exemple ainsi comment
envisagez-vous de tresser cette question
des freins à périphérique vous annoncez
également rénover le cadre d'engagement
réciproque dans une logique équilibrée
de droits et devoirs réciproque autour
d'une nouvelle contractualisation et
d'un nouveau régime de contrôle et de
sanctions plus juste plus progressif
mais aussi plus rapide aussi comment
appréhendez-vous cette notion de
conditionnalité de l'aide vis-à-vis du
risque de fragilisation des publics
fragiles enfin une matière de
temporalité comment entendez-vous
articuler ce projet de loi en question
avec les expérimentations en cours dans
18 territoires pilotes je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail de plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député Paul
Christophe en matière de RSA les
résultats collectifs que nous avons ne
sont pas satisfaisants pas satisfaisant
parce que si le RSA est une allocation
de subsistance de survie même pour
beaucoup les résultats en matière
d'insertion ne sont pas à la hauteur de
ce que nous pouvons espérer la Cour des
comptes l'a montré 7 ans après une
première inscription au RSA quatre
allocataires sur 10 sont toujours
bénéficiaires du RSA et seulement trois
sur 10 on retrouvait un emploi et sur
ces trois seulement 1 en réalité un
emploi stable nous devons donc faire
mieux et ce que nous poursuivons
l'objectif que nous nous vivons avec la
première ministre est justement de faire
mieux en renforçant la compagnement
renforcer l'accompagnement ces deux
choses c'est à la référence sorte que du
temps soit consacré pour lever les
freins périphériques les freins
périphériques que vous avez évoqué les
questions de garde d'enfant d'accès au
logement les questions de mobilité les
questions parfois de santé de ce qu'il
s'agit de permettre à nos locataires de
savoir exactement quel est le type de
fonction qu'il peut exercer ne le ferons
pas seul nous le ferons avec les
collectivités locales avec l'ensemble
des acteurs associatifs dans le cadre
d'une gouvernance locale que nous
voulons la plupart partager possible
allez plus loin et avoir un meilleur
accompagnement c'est aussi mettre en
place des activités d'insertion et de
formation nous ne sommes pas dans une
logique de travail gratuit ni dans une
logique de bénévolat obligatoire mais
bien d'accompagnement et d'insertion
nous considérons que pour être efficace
il faut consacrer entre 15 et 20 heures
par semaine à accompagner les publics et
ainsi leur permettre de retrouver le
chemin de l'emploi il s'agit
effectivement d'être dans une logique
d'engagement réciproque ça n'est pas une
nouveauté c'est la loi de 1988 créant le
RMI qui avait prévu cette logique
d'engagement
si un allocataire à qui est proposé un
parcours adapté adapté à ses besoins
adaptés aussi à ces difficultés refusent
délibérément d'y participer bien
évidemment que les sections les
sanctions pour être mises en place de la
suspension jusqu'à la radiation nous
travaillons le département du Nord est
un bon exemple avec 18 départements dans
le cadre d'expérimentation qui ont
débuté ces semaines-là et qui vont se
poursuivre pendant plusieurs mois la loi
que j'aurais présenté devant vous dans
quelques semaines fixera le cadre les
principes généraux et les
expérimentations nous permettront de
nourrir dans un échange de bonnes
pratiques avec assemblée des
départements de France les meilleures
accompagnements dans les mois qui
viennent merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe n'aillet pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre
vous êtes venu à la Réunion il y a
quelques jours par avion évidemment
aujourd'hui chez nous il n'y a pas
seulement les températures qui sont
au-dessus de la moyenne il y a surtout
le prix des billets d'avion qui ne
cessent d'augmenter en une année en une
année seulement pour la destination
outre-mer hexagone le prix moyen a
augmenté de 36% chacun comprend bien que
c'est une moyenne
auditionnée il y a quelques jours dans
le cadre la commission d'enquête de
Vichères pour les collectivités régies
par les articles 73 et 74 de notre
Constitution les opérateurs qui
interviennent dans nos territoires nous
ont dit la chose suivante le prix Les
prix des billets d'avion ne risque pas
de diminuer au contraire ils vont
continuer à augmenter pour des raisons
objectives qui nous ont été donnés
malgré les avancées technologiques c'est
une préoccupation pour les populations
de chez nous c'est une préoccupation
parce que derrière tout cela pèse
lourdement sur les Réunionnais sa
compromet la contribution de chacun à
son développement le développement du
territoire sa limite la mobilité pour
des raisons professionnelles de
formation d'hospitalisation dans
l'Hexagone cette situation risque
d'éloigner la réunion de l'Hexagone
comme les autres territoires
ultramarins ça un impact également pour
notre économie vous le savez madame la
Première ministre pour nous prendre
l'avion n'est pas un luxe nous demandons
simplement que chaque ultramarin puisse
se rendre dans des conditions
raisonnables ici dans l'Hexagone dans un
rapport récent du Sénat de mars de cette
année sur la continuité territoriale ce
rapport pointe notamment l'absence de
prise en compte des spécificités de
chaque territoire ultramarin et du
manque d'ambition des moyens quelle
mesure concrète comptez-vous prendre et
comment envisagez-vous d'assurer
l'accessibilité financière de la
continuité territoriale merci la parole
est à monsieur Clément bonne ministre
délégué chargé des transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Philippe Nayet comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire en réponse au député
qualifère au député Niort avec Gérald
Darmanin la semaine dernière la question
du prix des billets est extrêmement
sensible et très importante et je vais
récapituler un certain nombre d'actions
mais vous dire aussi que nous allons
faire plus dans les semaines qui
viennent la première ministre à
l'occasion de sa visite à La Réunion
s'est engagé pour le développement du
territoire et la continuité territoriale
en fait à l'évidence partie et c'est une
difficulté qui concerne beaucoup les
territoires et les outre-mer aujourd'hui
d'abord je l'ai dit et je le redis dans
le budget qui a été voté cette année
c'est en cours de déploiement les aides
et la continuité territoriale ont été
fortement revalorisées le 40 à 50% et en
ce moment même la Dom déploie un
programme pour soutenir l'achat d'un
certain nombre de billets d'avions le
sujet est malheureusement simple et
connu c'est en grande partie la question
de la hausse des prix du carburant qui
frappe la destination les outre-mer mais
aussi beaucoup de destinations longue
distance aujourd'hui dans l'aviation
néanmoins il faut regarder s'il n'y a
pas des rentes les mauvais comportements
et plusieurs solutions sont à l'étude
d'abord je l'ai dit tout à l'heure en
répondant aux députés kalifères il faut
maintenir une concurrence tout en
préservant les compagnies aériennes
actuelles en regardant aussi des
restructurations doivent être
encouragées c'est ce que nous faisons
avec le ministre caraco au service de
cette continuité territoriale je
réunirai les compagnies aériennes dans
les prochains jours avant la fin du mois
de mai pour avant la saison d'été faire
un point sur cette question les prix et
vérifier qu'il n'y a pas de mauvais
comportement ou de comportement
tarifaire qui serait excessif je le
redis je suis avec le ministre caracall
le ministre d’armanin à disposition des
élus des Outre-mer sur cette question
précise pour d'ici le début du mois de
juin faire une réunion avec le ministère
de l'Économie également pour examiner
cette question précise et puis il faut
refondre les aides de la Dom je crois
que c'est important c'est un chantier
que nous avons ouvert avec Jean-François
caraco j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs élus des Outre-mer qui m'ont
interpellé à ce sujet si nous
travaillons sur ces aides nous
travaillons avec les compagnies
aériennes vérifions qu'il n'y a aucun
comportement excessif ou dévoyé je pense
que nous apporterons des solutions
concrètes et puis bien sûr il faut aussi
essayer de réduire progressivement les
coûts des carburants mais nous agirons
encore davantage dans les prochaines
semaines
la parole est à Monsieur Jordan Guitton
pour le rassemblement national merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances pendant des
mois les Français ont payé le carburant
après de 2 euros le litre et leur
pouvoir d'achat a été fortement impacté
depuis des semaines et malgré une légère
baisse la France est l'un des pays en
Europe ou le carburant est encore le
plus cher je vous rappelle que la
voiture n'est pas un choix mais une
nécessité qu'elle s'impose aux familles
comme aux travailleurs pour des millions
de Français chaque matin notamment dans
les territoires ruraux comme dans mon
département de l'Aube le prix du
carburant hors taxes est à la fois l'un
des plus élevés d'Europe à cause
notamment de fortes marges sur le
raffinage et sur la distribution mais il
est aussi l'un des plus d'accès d'Europe
à environ 60% du prix à la pompe il faut
arrêter cette double peine pour rendre
leur argent aux Français et enfin
instaurer une véritable paix fiscale en
adoptant des mesures qui permettent de
contrer les eaux-volées actuelles ou
futur des prix du carburant comme la
baisse de TVA et la suppression des
hausses de la TICPE décidé par Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 car avec un gouvernement
rassemblement national ces mesures
permettraient une baisse durable du prix
du carburant et il serait aujourd'hui à
moins de 1,50 € le litre alors monsieur
le ministre mes questions sont simples
cette situation dure depuis des semaines
pourquoi avoir annoncé seulement il y a
quelques jours que vous alliez demander
au distributeur de baisser leur prix et
quand allez-vous appliquer enfin la
mesure pérenne et de bon sens portée par
Marine Le Pen et le rassemblement
national qui concerne la baisse de la
TVA de 20 à 5,5% sur l'ensemble des
énergies dont le carburant et qui
permettrait une baisse durable du prix
par litre
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès panier rue nacher ministre de la
transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Gitton il arrive votre rassemblement
national de prendre conscience que la
France n'a pas de pétrole et pourtant
vous qui vous dites patriote vous ne
proposez aucune proposition pour sortir
de cette dépendance alors face au peur
que vous agitez au mensonge que vous
déployez et ma collègue Olivia Grégoire
a eu assez largement eu l'occasion de
vous répondre sur une partie de ses
mensonges la baisse de la TVA la réalité
des prix et face à votre inaction
lorsqu'il s'agit de voter des mesures de
protection du pouvoir d'achat nous nous
agissons j'ai exigé effectivement ces
jours derniers des distributeurs et des
fournisseurs qu'il répercutent plus
rapidement la baisse des prix je me
permets de vous signaler qu'une partie
de la hausse que auquel faisait face les
Français étaient liés au blocage et aux
difficultés auxquelles nous avons dû
faire face ils ont dû faire face pour
fournir du carburant en français cette
baisse elle s'est concrétisée ces
derniers jours et nous continuons
être vigilant sur le prix du carburant
cela nous satisfait pas et c'est pour ça
que le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités a mis en place une
indemnité carburant qui bénéficie aux
Français qui effectivement ont besoin de
leur voiture pour aller travailler c'est
5 millions de Français qui bénéficient
cette indemnité carburant environ 7
indemnités vous ne l'avez pas voté de
même que sur la transition énergétique
qui au fond la solution de moyen terme
pour permettre aux Français de ne pas
avoir à subir cette dépendance aux
énergies fossiles sur lequel vous ne
faites aucune proposition ces mesures de
prime à la conversion de bonus
écologique de leasing à 100 euros que
nous allons prochainement mettre en
place ces mesures nous les déployons
aujourd'hui et là encore vous n'avez
aucune proposition précise qui
permettent d'accompagner ces Français
alors on savait que la Lorraine n'avait
pas de pétrole on découvre ou plutôt
c'est pas une découverte qui n'ont pas
plus d'idées
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur Guitton madame la ministre les
revenus de la TVA ont augmenté pour
votre gouvernement de 46 milliards
d'euros ces trois dernières années
arrêtez de taxer les automobilistes vous
êtes pas les Mozarts de la finance vous
êtes les Mozarts de la taxe rendez
l'argent aux Français
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Corinne Vignon
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des Armées monsieur
le ministre new frontier cette
expression utilisée en 1960 dans son
discours d'investiture par le président
Kennedy faisait référence au défi à
venir pour les futurs décennies en
lançant la course de l'espace
compte tenu du contexte international
avec le retour de la guerre de haute
intensité aux portes de l'Europe cette
expression est tragiquement d'actualité
l'espace est devenu le nouveau front de
conflictualité
le 13 juillet dernier le président de la
République annonçait une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire de 2024 à 2030
qui fixe les grands axes de notre
politique de défense pour renforcer et
tendre nos capacités spatiales de
défense 6 milliards d'euros ils seront
consacrés
afin de répondre à cette ambition le
commandement de l'espace basé dans ma
circonscription à Toulouse aura une
infrastructure militaire avait près de
500 experts en 2025 ce bâtiment dédié
représentera le symbole du spatial
militaire français
même si nous avons une avancée
considérable d'autres États se sont
lancés dans la maîtrise de l'espace face
à nous nous avons de sérieux
compétiteurs nous devons surveiller
l’activité de toutes nos orbites
protéger nos satellites nos moyens de
communication et nos équipements
militaires
cette nouvelle frontière le newspace est
aujourd'hui en proie des menaces c'était
le PM doit également porter une
politique spatiale ambitieuse pour la
France ainsi Monsieur le Ministre quel
est votre vision pour le spatial afin de
contrer d'éventuelles attaques comment
anticiper l'évolution de nos capacités
de télécommunication spatiale à horizon
2030 et après cette date ne faut-il pas
s'appuyer sur les constellations notre
avancée industrielle sur l'observation
depuis l'espace est indéniable mais
comment la LPM prévoit-t-elle de
consolider cette avance je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Sébastien Lecornu ministre
des Armées merci madame la Présidente
Messieurs les Députés madame députés
Vignon on vous l'avait dit l'ensemble de
l'ambition spatiale pour la LPM c'est 6
milliards d'euros sur la période et 50%
par rapport à la période précédente si
on reprend les différentes fonctions
stratégiques et opérationnelles telles
que vous les avez mentionnés en fin de
question on y retrouve bien sûr l'enjeu
sur les télécommunications
avec évidemment l'envoi dans l'espace du
satellite Syracuse 4B d'ailleurs ça sera
un symbole pour les derniers lancements
de la fusée Ariane 5 au mois de juin
l'inscription dans la LPM des études
pour la construction de la génération de
Syracuse 5 et pour répondre clairement à
votre question oui il y a des pistes de
travail actuels sur des constellations
en orbite basse ou des achats de service
notamment en redondance évidemment on
garde dans notre cœur de souveraineté
sur les gros satellites en orbite haute
notre propre savoir-faire et notre
propre maîtrise deuxième segment
l'observation actuellement génération
CSO un satellite coi est prévu en 2024
dans notre programmation militaire et je
peux confirmer madame la député vous
étiez en commission la défense nationale
avec un certain nombre d'entre de vos
collègues ici que les discussions avec
l'industriel se sont bien passées que
donc la semaine prochaine je vais
pouvoir porter un amendement du
Gouvernement à notre programmation
militaire qui va permettre d'inscrire un
satellite supplémentaire iris dès cette
loi programmation militaire dans cette
période sans attendre
[Applaudissements]
avec Emmanuel Macron et son gouvernement
les Français découvrent un nouveau
best-seller 50 nuances de mensonges car
après les mensonges sur les retraites
voici venu les intox sur la
réindustrialisation du pays
il est faux de dire que votre politique
de casse du droit du travail et de
cadeaux fiscaux aux investisseurs
étrangers créent des emplois entre fin
2019 et fin 2022 se sont 3900 emplois
temps plein qui ont disparu dans
l'industrie il est faux de dire que les
investissements étrangers sont le
meilleur moyen de réindustrialiser la
France ces investissements mettent en
danger notre souveraineté dans des
secteurs stratégiques la réalité c'est
que 10% des investissements entrants
sont de l'optimisation fiscale ce sont
des milliards d'euros qui échappent à
l'impôt la réalité c'est que 20% sont de
la pure spéculation immobilière qui est
la cause de la crise du logement en
France faites comme au Canada
interdisait ses investissements
surtout il est faux et fou d'exiger
comme le fait Emmanuel Macron une pause
réglementaire écologique non le problème
de l'industrie en France ce n'est pas la
règlementation écologique le problème
c'est le prix de l'énergie qui menace
150 000 emplois dans notre pays vous
refusez de revenir au tarif réglementé
alors même que cet assemblée la voté au
contraire de ce que vous faites il faut
instaurer des contreparties sociales et
écologiques il faut par exemple
renforcer les règles dans les
co-conception sujet totalement absent de
votre projet de loi industrie verte vous
avez été condamné trois fois pour une
action climatique c'est à dire pour ne
rien faire pour atteindre les objectifs
carbone ma question est donc simple
comment comptez-vous faire moins que
rien
merci la parole est à Monsieur Roland
Lescure ministre délégué chargé de
l'Industrie merci merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Sofia Chikirou
nous avons reçu avec Bruno Le Maire le 9
avril dernier avec une délégation de
votre groupe en vous proposant comme un
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires ici au Sénat de
contribuer à ce projet de loi et donc
vous êtes la bienvenue pour les idées
que vous avez égrainées sur la fin de
votre question pour y contribuer y
compris d'un point de vue traditionnel
j'irai dans le cadre des examens en
commission et un assemblée mais
contribue à un projet de loi suppose
quand même d'être d'accord sur les faits
au départ les faits madame shikiro ils
sont têtus
mais entre 2017 et le dernier chiffre
connu c'est à dire le premier trimestre
de 2023 nous avons créé la France a créé
cette majorité à créer 90 000 emplois
dans l'industrie madame la députée
shikiro vous avez pris les chiffres
puisque je vais prendre les vôtres et je
vais répondre entre décembre 2019 et
descendre 2022 alors c'est sûr que si
vous choisissez les dates qui vous
adorent vous allez sans doute arriver à
prouver quoi après vrai que malgré ce
que vous dites entre le début de la
covid et la fin 2022 l'industrie qui
évidemment avait plongé comme tous les
secteurs de l'économie pendant la covid
a quasiment retrouvé le niveau qui
prévalait avant et je le répète et je le
répéterai tant que l'INSEE vous le dira
sur l'ensemble du quinquennat c'est 90
000 emplois industriels ces 300 usines
en plus qui existent en France
c'est des usines qui sont en train de
décarboner l'industrie traditionnelle
alors vous parlez de pose réglementaires
moi je vous parle de décarbonate
l'industrie traditionnelle qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les 56 les plus émetteurs
sont en train de dégager et d'adopter
des plans ambitieux qui font que 60% des
émissions de l'industrie française vont
bientôt être un mauvais souvenir alors
oui on a besoin de l'industrie oui on a
besoin de la décarbonée et oui on a
besoin d'aider la nouvelle industrie qui
va créer les emplois de demain chez vous
et partout en France et ne vous en
déplaise ce projet de loi il va
accélérer il va simplifier il va
augmenter toutes les actions que nous
avons menées pendant 5 ans
merci beaucoup monsieur
la parole est à Madame Louise Morel pour
le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Agnès panier rue
naché ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre la France
est plus que jamais engagée pour mener
la bataille contre le dérèglement
climatique et pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone notre pays a des
atouts stratégiques pour réussir et
notamment un mix électrique parmi les
plus décarbonés au monde grâce à notre
parc nucléaire toutefois nous devons
aller encore plus loin plus vite et
c'est ce que nous allons faire cet
après-midi dans cette hémicycle en
votant pour le projet de loi
d'accélération des procédures
d'installation nucléaire disons-le
clairement c'est bien aux côtés de
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable de l'accélération
du lancement d'un grand programme
nucléaire que notre pays réussira à
bâtir sa souveraineté énergétique en
cela nos posons pas les énergies
renouvelables au nucléaires notre défi
c'est de mettre fin aux énergies
fossiles madame la ministre le nucléaire
n'est pas seulement un pour la France
c'est également un atout pour l'Europe
et vous portez dans ces négociations
européennes l'intégration du nucléaire
comme énergie essentielle à la
transition énergétique la France a eu de
nombreuses victoires la taxonomie
européenne plus récemment la production
d'hydrogène des carbonée avec de
l'énergie nucléaire alors qu'elle était
tabou il y a encore peu de temps ce
succès est dû à un important travail
diplomatique et de conviction auprès de
nos homologues européens alors ma
question porte sur l'alliance du
nucléaire vous en êtes madame la
ministre à l'initiative et la première
réunion s'est tenue le 28 février à
Stockholm avec 11 pays ce matin ce sont
16 pays qui étaient représentés dans
votre ministère pour une nouvelle
réunion de cette alliance c'est une
démonstration de la place de la France
sur ce sujet et de la preuve que le
nucléaire a une place essentielle dans
la transition énergétique européenne
alors madame la ministre pourriez-vous
nous présenter la feuille de route de
l'alliance du nucléaire au service de la
transition énergétique ique européenne
et plus particulièrement quelle
conclusion tirez-vous de la réunion avec
vos homologues ce matin je vous remercie
beaucoup ma chère collègues la parole
est à Madame ma nièce panier renacher
ministre de la transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Morel je le partage avec vous le défi de
notre siècle c'est de mettre fin à
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles et
ce n'est donc ne pas opposer les
énergies renouvelables et les énergies
nucléaires ou l'énergie nucléaire car
nous allons avoir besoin de ces deux
leviers comme nous avons besoin
d'ailleurs de sobriété énergétique et
d'efficacité énergétique
j'appelle donc l'ensemble des députés de
tout bord confondus à voter le projet
loi d'accélération des procédures
nucléaires que nous allons
évalu nous allons regarder tout à
l'heure pour bâtir cette souveraineté
énergétique c'est une étape essentielle
pour lancer dans les meilleurs délais le
grand programme nucléaire que nous
appelons de nos vœux c'est une étape
essentielle pour envoyer à la filière
nucléaire un signal fort de soutien et
de mobilisation générale c'est une étape
essentielle aussi pour marquer la
volonté de la France de réussir sa
transition énergétique grâce clair et au
fond cette volonté que je partage avec
vous c'est celle que nous avons partagée
avec les 16 pays que nous avons réunies
ce matin à Paris pour construire cette
alliance du nucléaire cette alliance du
nucléaire d'abord elle incorpore la
Commission européenne puisque quadrice
Simpson la commissaire énergie était à
nos côtés pour discuter de notre feuille
de route son but c'est d'établir une
feuille de route ambitieuse qui nous
permette très vite d'accélérer notre
transition énergétique l'accélérer en
montrant que nous sommes tous en train
de lancer de nouveaux projets nucléaires
des projets nucléaires qui pourraient
nous permettre de créer jusqu'à 450
000 emplois dans les années qui viennent
c'est absolument considérable des
projets qui vont nous permettre de
soutenir notre filière nucléaire et vous
savez que la France il prendra toute sa
place des projets qui visent également à
ce que le nucléaire soit
systématiquement inclus dans notre
stratégie énergétique européenne et
c'est avec la plus grande détermination
que nous allons porter ensemble cette
vision en fin dernier point les
compétences
vous avez dépassé votre temps largement
la parole est à Monsieur Vincent Roland
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre c'est le printemps
nous sommes en montagne et comme chaque
année nos agriculteurs ressortent leur
troupeau après l'hiver ils sont les
ambassadeurs d'une agriculture de
qualité qui fait la réputation du
territoire l'entretien des paysages
ainsi que la gestion des sols contre
l'érosion aux yeux du grand public cette
situation pourrait paraître parfait mais
elle ne l'est pas du tout pourquoi la
réponse est simple c'est la pression
insupportable qu'exerce le loup sur nos
élevages nos éleveurs sont à bout
quelques chiffres ce sont aujourd'hui
bien plus de 1000 loups présents sur le
territoire national
12000 bêtes victimes de ces attaques
sans compter la faune elle aussi
atteinte ce sont aussi 60 millions
d'euros prélevés dans la poche du
contribuable pour protéger une espèce
pourtant en voie de fortes expansions
madame la Première ministre le loup est
partout en France il va même jusqu'à
rentrer dans nos villages il tue des
chiens et n'est même plus effarouchée
par la présence des habitants faut-il
attendre un drame humain pour prendre
des mesures appropriées aussi nous vous
demandons de changer de paradigme avec
une nouvelle politique de gestion de
l'espèce en facilitant les tirs par mois
de bureaucratie en utilisant des
lunettes et caméra thermique y compris
pour les agriculteurs et quel que soit
le type d'élevage et en supprimant le
reste à charge pour les éleveurs nous
vous demandons un changement profond de
la position de l'État il en va de
l'avenir de l'élevage comme de la vie de
nos agriculteurs je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Bérengère Couillard secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'écologie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Roland d'abord sachez que nous mesurons
bien sûr la détresse des éleveurs
français face aux attaques du loup et
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
particulièrement avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture qui est absent aujourd'hui
mais qui partage évidemment le souhait
bien sûr Marc feno qui partage le
souhait de trouver des solutions
pertinentes et les plus adaptées bien
sûr pour pour y faire face vous le savez
le loup est une espèce qui est qui est
protégé par la Convention de Berne et
qui est revenu par les Alpes françaises
depuis maintenant une trentaine d'années
notre priorité elle est d'assurer nos
engagements de protection du loup mais
aussi et bien sûr de permettre aux
pastoralisme d'exercer son activité dans
les meilleures conditions c'est en ce
sens que nous avons adopté en 2018 un
plan national d'action notamment pour la
mise en face de mesures de protection
des troupeaux vous le savez des aides au
gardiennage pour les berges par les
bergers aux achats de clôture également
de chiens de protection le gouvernement
met également en oeuvre une politique de
tir des rogatoire en 2022 ce sont 169
loups qui ont été prélevés sur un
plafond de 164 ce qui représente 19% de
la population estimée je dois rappeler
que ce sont prioritairement les attaques
de troupeau que nous devons régler
afin d'adopter bien sûr des mesures
toujours plus efficaces et dans un
esprit de dialogue que nous souhaitons
préserver et d'une concertation que nous
devons assurer j'ai lancé à la demande
de la première ministre Elisabeth borne
un plan d'action nationale sur la
période
2024-2029 qui est basé sur une
concertation avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et on aura notamment
l'occasion d'en rediscuter évidemment
avec les parlementaires les
organisations professionnelles agricoles
également les associations de protection
de l'environnement je souhaite
évidemment que ce travail aboutisse et
nous y sommes très attachés avec le
ministre merci beaucoup madame la
secrétaire d'État monsieur le député
madame la ministre je suis pas sûr que
ces propos rassurent le mandra agricole
et nous voudrions vous entendre dire que
pour vous le gouvernement c'est
l'agriculture avant le loup merci la
parole est à Madame Mirac Lapo pour logo
Renaissance merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre de des Affaires
étrangères vendredi dernier nous avons
appris la libération de deux français
détenus en Iran depuis plusieurs mois
Benjamin Brière et Bernard féland la
grève de la faim pour dénoncer leur
détention arbitraire à hélas lourdement
impacter leur santé souhaitons leur de
se remettre de ces terribles épreuves
alors merci merci aux agents du centre
de crise et de soutien du ministère
merci aux diplomates français merci à
vous madame la ministre pour avoir
permis ce dénouement la libération et la
protection consulaire des détenus
français doivent être une priorité comme
l'avait rappelé notre assemblée dans sa
résolution en soutien au mouvement pour
la liberté du peuple iranien en novembre
malheureusement quatre autres de nos
concitoyens sont toujours détenus en
Iran là aussi dans des conditions
intolérables l'Iran utilise nos
concitoyens comme des otages d'État les
accusants arbitrairement d'espionnage
mettant même en scène des aveux forcé de
leur part
l'Iran se joue de l'État de droit même
après le acquittement certains sont
maintenus en détention ou assignés à
résidence comme fariba adelka
soyons lucides ces agissements
constituent très probablement des
mesures de rétorsion à l'encontre de
ceux qui soutiennent le peuple iranien
et qui comme la France ont soutenu le
mouvement femme vie liberté ou dénoncer
sa terrible répression par les autorités
iraniennes cette réponse de l'Iran par
la diplomatie des otages doit cesser
c'est l'honneur de notre diplomatie
d'autant plus de notre diplomatie
féministe de dénoncer inlassablement les
violations des droits humains et des
textes que la République islamique
d'Iran à elle-même signée
madame la ministre quels sont les
actions que mène le ministère pour la
libération et la protection de nos
concitoyens toujours retenus en Iran
comment empêcher l'Iran de continuer
ainsi c'est insupportable diplomatie des
otages je vous remercie merci beaucoup
ma chère collègue la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
clapot merci de votre question qui nous
permet d'évoquer deux libération
de bonnes nouvelles donc nous avons eu
en effet la joie de pouvoir accueillir
vendredi dernier Benjamin Brière
de retour en France après avoir été
détenus sans raison en Iran le premier
depuis 3 ans
et le second pendant 8 mois ils ont pu
retrouver leur famille et nous sommes
tous très heureux avec elle mesdames et
messieurs les députés tout le
gouvernement se réjouit de leur
libération et je suis sûr que vous vous
en réjouissez également
alors madame la députée nous n'avions eu
de cesse de plaider auprès des autorités
iraniennes pour la libération de Bernard
féland et de Benjamin Brière sur des
bases humanitaires l'un et l'autre étant
malade étant affaibli au point qu'ils
sont encore aujourd'hui hospitalisés
tous les deux
je remercie tous ceux qui ont
œuvré à ce résultat et je remercie
d'avoir cité un certain nombre d'entre
eux dont des agents de mon ministère et
je dois souligner de surcroît la très
bonne coordination entre les différentes
administrations françaises qui ont eu à
oeuvrer pour ce bon résultat mais après
ces libération et après celle de Farida
delcaque je vous remercie d'avoir évoqué
il nous reste encore à obtenir la
libération de 4 de nos compatriotes
nous ne relâcherons en rien nos efforts
et nous exons leur libération immédiate
et sans condition et je t'ai enfin
rappelé que pour ceux qui concerne les
seuls pays de l'Union européenne il
reste 35 personnes retenues
ressortissant d'une douzaine d'État
membres est avec lesquelles nous sommes
solidaires et qui sont confrontés comme
nous le sommes à une politique
inacceptable et que nous dénonçons merci
madame la députée merci beaucoup madame
la ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente pano pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Première ministre vous occupez
votre poste depuis un an sans que
personne ici ne vous ai accordé son vote
de confiance depuis un an de 49,3 en
49.3 vous assurez le service après-vente
des caprices du président de la
République en l'espace d'un an vous avez
fait de notre pays une poudrière bravo
Madame la première ministre quel
anniversaire aujourd'hui encore le
président de la République vit dans une
réalité parallèle à présent Emmanuel
Macron est le seul qui croit encore en
Emmanuel Macron vous êtes les seuls dans
le pays qui croit pouvoir tourner la
page nouveau répondons jamais jamais
nous n'accepterons de vous voyez deux
ans de vie aux Français 34000 euros de
retraite à chacun d'eux et que vous les
brutalisiez au propre comme au figuré le
pays tout entier opposé à votre réforme
les syndicats comme le Parlement bravo
Madame la première ministre quel
anniversaire la macronie se vit à
présent comme une
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre tant
comprendrez-vous que la représentation
nationale n'est mise en paillasson ni
une chambre d'enregistrement des lubies
du président madame la Première ministre
joyeux anniversaire surtout n'hésitez
pas à partir vous la Cinquième
République et votre réforme des
retraites
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la Présidente panneaux
alors on l'a bien compris vous êtes
définitivement fâché avec nos
institutions parce que le programme que
nous mettons en œuvre madame la
Présidente panneau c'est celui sur
lequel le président de la République a
été élu et définitivement vous ne la ne
mettez pas mais ce n'est pas Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Emmanuel Macron que les
Français ont choisi et je vous le
confirme nous continuerons à mettre en
œuvre le programme pour lequel le
président de la République a été élu et
vous de votre côté madame la Présidente
panneau c'est grave ce que vous faites
vous montez aux Français vous mentez aux
Français
du matin au soir vous mentez aux
Français vous voulez faire croire qu'on
pourrait d'un traître plume rayé 18
milliards d'euros de recettes pour notre
système de retraite alors une fois pour
une fois dites aux Françaises que vous
proposez vous proposez de baisser les
pensions vous proposez d'augmenter les
cotisations et de baisser le pouvoir
d'achat des travailleurs pour une fois
dites la vérité voyez madame panot et
vous et vraiment vous êtes fâchés aussi
avec le fonctionnement de cette
Assemblée nationale vous avez fait de
l'obstruction de l'obstruction à cause
de vous madame la Présidente panneau
malgré 82 80 heures de débats vos
collègues n'ont pas pu examiner au-delà
de l'article 3 de la réforme des
retraites et maintenant après
l'obstruction d'un texte qui a été
approuvé qui a été validé par le Conseil
mais qui a été validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel qu'est-ce que vous
proposez au bout aujourd'hui vous
proposez d'abroger la réforme c'est tout
à fait représentatif de ce que vous êtes
madame la Présidente panneau et de ce
que vous proposez de votre groupe des
propositions jamais mais par contre
attisé les colères
empêcher le Parlement de fonctionner
c'est ça votre mode de fonctionnement
pour notre cylindre pour notre plaid ce
que nous voulons c'est proposer des
réponses aux Français et pas plus tard
que tout à l'heure j'engagerai des
concertations avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales pour construire
de nouveaux progrès
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la séance des questions est
terminée la séance est suspendue
[Applaudissements]